so what is really working on YouTube
right now to grow your channel to get
more views to get subscribers especially
as a Christian content creator and what
does this small Hatchet axe have to do
with success might seem like a random
opening but I actually want to kick off
today's coffee with canel with a Bible
verse because we're going to be going
through three coaching sessions stick
around until the end because there's
going to be massive tactics that will
help you ultimately impact more people
grow your channel um but one of the
powerful Bible verses that changed my
life years ago was Ecclesiastes 10:10
and it says this using adult AE requires
great strength so sharpen the blade
that's the value of wisdom it helps you
succeed and actually a few years ago um
we had a theme at think media and it was
sharpen the axe we always have an annual
theme and so this little axe here with
the cool little leather sheath says
thank on there and then uh ultimately my
son will climb up to get this very
dangerous uh and you can see we got that
Bible verse right on there well why do
we love this verse it's because that
sometimes when you're trying to grow
your YouTube channel you're trying to
grow your personal brand brand it feels
exhausting it feels like a slog it feels
like you're sweating you're perspiring
you're super overwhelmed because using
adult acts requires great strength so
what the author of Ecclesiastes King
Solomon encourages us to do is he says
Hey so sharpen the blade and that's
actually the value of wisdom it helps
you succeed if you take some time to
actually sharpen the blade you're able
to accomplish your goals faster if
you're feeling fatigued right now and
frustrated because your Channel's not
growing maybe you need to sharpen the
blade if you're feeling like man I just
haven't quite figured out my Niche or my
positioning or my business model I see
the opportunity to grow my church to
grow my Ministry to grow my personal
brand as a Christian content creator but
like it's not quite working yet I want
to encourage you sharpen the blade why
do some people make success seem
effortless well it could be because they
took the time to sit down learn study
skill up tool up get new strategies new
tactics and in doing so by taking the
time to sharpen the blade they
ultimately reach their goals faster and
before we get into our first coaching
session um it reminds me of a quote by
Abraham Lincoln that said hey if I've
got eight hours to chop down a tree I'm
GNA spend the first six sharpening the
axe you know he was referencing the
Bible when he said that quote because he
was saying listen it's not just
necessarily about more hard work it's
actually about more smart work it's
about being more intentional and taking
time to sharpen the blade and that's
what we do here on coffee with Kel and
that's what we're going to be doing in
these convers ation so I really believe
the next 90 minutes or so after we go
through the three coaching sessions and
after we do some Q&A with our guests and
whether you're here live on the replay
drop replay fam in the comments smash
like because I really believe this is
going to be a powerful episode of coffee
with canel so buckle your seat belt hit
the like button and let's dive into the
show
[Music]
back to the coffee with canel show my
name is Sean canell rhymes with YouTube
channel super grateful that you're here
and in just a second we're gon to get in
to our first guest Myra Kate we've got
Stephen here today Chris and Meg here
today and uh there's gonna be a lot of
tactical lessons that you learn let me
know what you're drinking though I'm
sipping on some um coffee from prea and
Arizona it's a Columbia blend today
prepared it in an aerrow
press it's delicious and um I'm super
fired up today's episode is brought to
you by vid iq.com thinkink a little bit
more on that later but you can get a
30-day trial of vid iq's boost plan for
just $11 at vid iq.com
think and today's episode is brought to
you by expand good kingdom.com if you
haven't heard we are doing a free
YouTube strategy class for Christian
content creators live that if you're
watching live it's happening today in
five hours or something like that from
when we started this and so that's at
expand Goods kingdom.com so check that
out in the show notes and um we'll
Circle back on some of those things in
just a bit and I want to welcome Myra
Kate to coffee with Kaa canel how's it
going hey there thank you so much for
having me here I'm so grateful to be
here it's 3:00 a.m. here
though like green farts or something
don't worry I mean the honors all mine
to get up at 3:00 a.m. to be on the show
I'm so humbled and grateful we have an
international community and that
technology allows us to do this and so
thank you for being here and I'm going
to pull your channel up but give us a
little uh uh Vision about what is it
you're doing on YouTube what is your
goal when did you get
started yeah so uh I got started with
YouTube um years back um um but I never
really became that much active um and I
just restarted it uh this year uh June
um and I really honed into to the SR
system of the V I haven't completely
finished the V program yet but we're
getting there um and yeah I have seen um
quite a few like results in the past few
um the past few weeks where when I have
started uh becoming active in this and
mo mostly I just really um upload course
creation videos uh course creation
strategies and all of that for Kingdom
driven entrepreneurs so yeah I love it I
love it and so um you were wondering how
to get some more views right now you're
averaging 100 to 200 uh a little bit
about thumbnails and then monetization
questions is that what you want to cover
today yes yes that would be really
awesome awesome well let's dive into it
it's kind of cool to see that you know
first that eight years ago it looks like
you uh uploaded this video though as far
as when the channel started yes that is
when I was still back in like
uni yeah that's awesome and so more
recently you're
saying uh did you kind of you formed a
business to coach course creators
correct Christian um right now I do have
um course creation done for you services
and programs for um yeah for Christian
experts that's Fierce Clarity to have I
mean for 99% of people I don't know
about those numbers but a lot of times
um having a product or a service first
can really help you of course architect
what it is you're even doing on YouTube
so that's um super helpful okay so let's
dive in um well a couple things um let's
go thumbnails first my personal
philosophy is three or less words on
thumbnails so the first thing I see
is too much words and a little too much
clutter on the channel overall uh kind
of overwhelms me now you look great your
your photos you in the in the thumbnails
the color scheme you've chosen all of
that's great and your ability to create
thumbnails I think um is incredible you
know I will say I know that this video
is two months old um so it's had a
little more time to get views and I will
say that topics vary in terms of results
but I find it interesting
that the best thumbnail out of these top
eight also has the most views it has
452 as opposed to even 347
241 and of course topic probably matters
more than anything but it also is the
most minimalist get your course done in
record time which is also a great
promise so my first thought is there's a
couple examples we could look at I think
we could look at um there's great
examples all over the place success
leaves Clues what we like to say at
think media could we do can we do no
words that's the most recent video with
Omar we were debating this in slack too
the original thumbnail that came out
yesterday was pretty terrible we started
to retool things work on things could we
do no words okay if we're going to do
words can we do three or yes one year
faceless that's three or less and some
cases it's just logos let me give
another example here I think Leila uh
heroi
and Alex as well U their director of
brand and person running their content
team is my good friend Caleb Ralston and
and uh if we look at you know some of
these thumbnails there's a lot more also
creativity a lot more saturation a lot
more contrast color um sometimes couple
words you don't need money and so it's
not like three words is also like has to
stop you if there is a phrase like
you're not thinking big enough or
something fine but if possible stop
hiring how could it be you know just two
words and so one
way if we talk about the perfect video
recipe related to your channel the
perfect video recipe which is the big
idea the hook the content and the
transition it starts with a big idea and
that is in V are we are we coming up
with the right topics title
thumbnail um of course then the content
itself we want to reinforce it with
great content
but I do think that if we can really get
that big idea idea dialed in and think
about defining your title ahead of time
your thumbnail ahead of time and
optimizing some of those things that
could be really helpful for us um and
you know even in this case how to
Outsource your online course creation to
get results how can we improve this um
you could say you could maybe just say
get your that one's almost perfect
though I think that one actually is
pretty good even though it's a little
bit more words sell your course without
a huge following tips for women coaches
and
entrepreneurs um the other mistake we
can make not only that helps us
eliminate words is there's no need to
Echo the title you already say without a
huge following and then it says even if
you don't have a big audience well if
that's already
communicated one of the most powerful
questions
we um ask in crafting any form of
content a video a course a book is what
can be taken away I think a creativity
we should always ask what could be
removed less is more can we
tell can we actually make the story
clear more
clear in a faster time with less words
could we get the point across in seven
minutes instead of 14 so just also
thinking
about let's see why you need to create
online courses as a female coach and
entrepreneur is creating courses wor
worth it now I think secondly I love
that you're doing the call out here uh
and I think I could debate that a little
bit I don't know if I would add female
Coast coach or entrepreneur I might just
leave it as why you need to create
online
courses and then understanding that that
then allows your video to go a little
bit more Broad and then once in your
video you could
articulate the fact that and hey if you
actually are looking for some done for
you service or whatnot I specialize in
help helping female coaches and
entrepreneurs so hit the link below but
it can help you increase your views by
maybe not going as narrow so narrow in
what you're doing um and it'll make the
title more lean it obvious the reason I
feel I feel tension on that is this very
stream is a good example like it's
literally YouTube tips and strategy for
Christian content creators um and so in
some cases it's it's good but what's
powerful about this is it does allow
allowed me to open up with the Bible
verse allowed me to like speak to more
of a particular group of people so it's
not that you should never call out that
audience but it's a question of broad
appeal versus or broader appeal because
already creating online courses is going
to attract certain people but then if
you're very articulated about your
articulated about your faith your values
what you believe someone might go might
find the video because it's recommended
to them and be like oh she's a Christian
I'm mad well good I mean at least they
were there you got a little watch time
you know and and then the person that's
like oh she has similar values to me
that's awesome then that could happen as
well and it could happen potentially a
little bit deeper which the more Niche
you go that is also going to be a cap on
your views so even your question of
could I get some more
views um and and then lastly along this
line of thought I think I would say that
um that the continuous continuous
following of the 7R system and really
specifically the first two RS research
and reverse engineer and really
mastering those is going to be huge
because all of us on the coffee with
candel today anyone on the replay we
really are one video away from changing
our life in business I agree and not
even just because of the one video also
because the one video unlocks
confidence the one video unlocks oh wow
I found something that resonated oh wow
that video not just did well but it led
to some comments so that should lead us
to two conclusions number one that we
shouldn't quit we got to keep posting
keep experimenting keep growing but two
that it's worth
architecting what is a hero topic that
would lead to 10,000 20,000 100,000
views and attract your ideal person what
is a hero video that you could make a
great title a great
thumbnail architect the
video and practically number one lead to
more leads clients and sales for your
services which could be life-changing
but then also number two it arising tide
lifts All Ships the one video lifts the
other videos and awareness of you but it
also builds your confidence to double
down on that video and the way we say it
is Success leaves Clues make part twos
so you saying I'm stuck at you know 100
to 200 real fact is though that's like
okay you're average but you're also very
capable of going 5,000 1,000 you know 5
00 so success leaves Clues make part
tw's
is thinking about what can you learn
should you be doubling down on AI this
is what this concludes to me could you
do a 10-part series on chat gbt that
concludes to me could could you you know
even if you were to
go uh chat
GPT uh course or uh for
online courses so you search that
because that's your best video so then
you start looking into it okay that's an
actual chat GPT course which in and of
itself might not be a bad thing to
create uh full online course with slides
and minutes
so you know Corey made this
video this would inspire me if I'm you
to maybe try to create an online course
with slides see what could happen do an
experiment so it would said you it could
send you down a path it would send me
down a path I'd be like okay success
leaves clu not just on my channel so let
me try to create a course with chat gbt
let me experiment and put the research
in and then out of me being the guinea
pig out of me being the experiment let
me then make the 510 part series on that
and then knowing your skill set just
from seeing what you've already
accomplished looking at this thumbnail
maybe check it out his video it's 12
minutes I don't see why you maybe you
don't get 50,000 views maybe you only
get 12,000 that's life-changing when
your most viewed video is 5,000 when it
attracts the right person it's exact
right thing and that was simply from
going to your most popular videos
looking at how we could maybe spin out
some other stuff around chat gbt but
then you step into AI That's that could
be a very profitable path on many levels
also could lead to Brand deals Etc
there's a lot of AI startups that want
to work with micro influencers right now
they're all struggling or pursuing
awareness they're looking for people it
could just be a photo generator graphic
it's literally endless that that for
your Niche this wouldn't necessarily
apply to everybody I think AI is going
to be life-changing for 100% of people
watching this and nobody should be
ignoring it they should be asking not
only how can I use it but could I be
creating content about it because it's
hot right now but for
you it's like you know literally it
could be hundreds of videos over the
next couple years so that was just from
looking there obviously maybe confidence
mindset is interesting maybe so that's
another five part series maybe on conf
confidence um Outsourcing so right there
we just got confidence Outsourcing and
Ai and boom now we steer and you just
said 100 to 200 so now everything we
just talked about and some thumbnail
tweaks and and improvements led to now
your problem is like why are my videos
stuck at 500 to 1,000 but we literally
just problem Rex your current so um any
has that been helpful at all yes
definitely I'm having a lot of ideas now
um especially when you said uh chat GPT
and also the confidence videos um I
could you know talk about um like tools
for course creators and also like chat
GPT prompts I guess you know things like
that that might be valuable as well for
um to make the course creation um more
streamlined and easy yeah yeah and
there's others like are you doing
affiliate marketing
already I am I have tried doing it but I
it hasn't really been that successful
for me um I should though I mean I want
to yeah but what do you
recommend like for people hosting their
course I uh use thinkific and kajabi for
all of my clients yeah yeah so imagine
if you also you should make a video
called think
ific versus
kajabi
and you know we got
2400 views here 10,000 views here um
they ranked them all there 3,000 views
here 108,000 views now that's the seven
best but here's why this is powerful and
notice I did versus and we teach V the
versus strategy the powerful thing about
that is you'll meet people right
when
they are at probably a buying decision
if they have narrowed it down like wow
I've studied kujabi and I've studied
thinkific and I'm not sure which one I
want there's a reason why the one of the
reasons why people struggle with
affiliate marketing is this they don't
architect
content strategically
engineered to lead to an actual sales
conversion of the product for example if
I was to
say Nordic Track versus
pelaton the person that even clicks on
that video or searches for that video
probably wants to spend some money on a
Nordic Track exercise bike or or a
pelaton and they're trying to make a
decision and if you make a great video
and you educate that it's in the
description they go okay I'm going to go
with the Nordic Track they click your
link you get the
commission so then you apply that to you
know three tips for getting more out of
your exercise bike well they already
have one potentially at that moment so
why would that video it's not at the
stage of a buyer Journey that there
might actually be a buying decision so
that one thing alone because the cool
thing about the course world is whether
it's crms whether it's hosting whether
it's something like kajabi that can do
all of the above eventually whether it's
plugins or other things you're
definitely in a world that is per you
know is really aligned with affiliate
marketing I would encourage you like you
said you know keep doubling down in V
keep V Masters is also updated we added
that whole Advanced section so um that
is uh all in the members area right now
you've got your Future's So Bright we
got to wear sunglasses like you got a
lot of opportunity ahead of you and um I
hope that this uh short session has been
helpful yes definitely it has been very
helpful and encouraging um the only
reason I was I could I I would want to
say though that the only reason I'm
really not um creating videos on those
Tech just yet is that sometimes it feels
like oh there's so many people who are
doing this already and like I don't even
know how my video would stand out or
help because you know somebody out there
might have already created um a a video
on that but then now it's like I'm like
fighting internally with
myself and let me just speak to that
mindset because this is why I love
sessions like this because it benefits
everybody that's here I I think
everybody has that mindset oh someone's
already done it someone's already talked
about it someone's already put the video
out but when something is a proven topic
you should do it as well and especially
when it's a proven strong topic and
there's desire for it you should do it
as well and here's why you know one of
the things um to prove this point is
thinking about the Canon M50 so the
Canon M50 honestly is a little outdated
now um still a great camera and man we
talked about it yeah we talked about it
for a lot of cameras meaning it's it's
like five years old right it's like six
years old yeah so it's not the most it's
not the latest tech it's a great camera
here's the point
think media has probably
made 30 videos on the Canon M50 so if we
go back Canon M50 tutorial is it dead
you won't like my answer Canon M50 seven
best camera settings photography
tutorial versus the zv E10 mark one Mark
versus Mark I so okay so then you go
okay well think media oh Sean already
has a head start oh Omar and Nolan oh th
media already has a head start I
shouldn't even make the video
oh well but what we don't realize is
also just how significant of a topic
that is and if you find a good topic and
everyone else has already done it well
no you should do it too and here's why
because yes maybe I'll get 50,000 or
Omar will get 50,000 or we'll get a
quarter million but people are
underestimating the chance to get 44,000
54,000 these are not think media 37,000
and look at all these other channels
Tech through the lens fail taale
whips um real fil filming tech gear talk
fail there's whips again Peak Coco
photography Plick prickly pair camera
tech gear
talk um let's
see and we could we could scroll we
could probably spend the rest of the day
live Ville rasu talking about the M50
126,000 he only has 2,000 subscribers
here this is why it also proves we talk
about this is like he only has 2500
subscribers but he got 126,000 views
which when you're doing topic research
that reveals how much interest and
desire there is in a topic and there's
another big secret that is revealed on
screen here that I'm about to share but
if anybody's getting value from this
conversation smash like because what
also proves that YouTube will never be
too crowded there will never be like too
much competition it can never be
saturated is this
fact is the Kon M50 Mark I worth it in
2023 Sean what do you mean I mean it's
always going to be a new year it's
always the whole dynamic is going to
change meaning the Canon M50 was the
best camera until a new camera was
created and then when a new camera was
created now there's a new versus maybe
it's still the best maybe there's that
one maybe now people are like the thing
that didn't even exist now exists and
that's why there will always be
opportunity on YouTube and it can never
be saturated so to be even more specific
if you were to
say kajabi versus thinkific in
20123 that is a a radically different
because it's not just like ever and
someone's looking at a video and they're
like well that's five years old
software the the race of building
software is always changing sometimes
the software is the best and it's
running fast and it's got a great
development team and sometimes they get
a new CEO and it's not as fast and
somebody comes out with better
technology so you can make an honest
video that's like at the end of the day
kajabi is better than think ific right
now but then when a new product shows up
or it's a new year just things are
changed a little bit or they haven't
changed because all this person is doing
is saying is the Canon M50 Mark II worth
it and they could be like yes here's why
or here's what it's compared to so as
the Earth circles the Sun and as
software is updated and as new AI tools
are created and as new disruptive
technology disrupts other technology
there's always new news to cover there's
always new topics to cover there's all
new there's always new comparisons to
make because you could take the
six-year-old M50 and compare it to the
brand new and you couldn't have done
that until the thing came out and we can
take advantage of in a loving Christlike
way people's laziness because people get
tired
people uh you know in Proverbs it says
uh cursed is the disgraceful son who
sleeps during the Harvest a lot of
people aren't seeing the opportunity
that's out here Thomas Edison said
opportunity is missed by most people
because it's dressed in overalls and
looks like work that's it's such a
Biblical principle like and and I'm not
trying to call people lazy but people
get complacent they get comfortable they
get lazy and there is unlimited topics
unlimited titles unlimited videos to
make and even if you go through a season
where it's a little dry boom all of a
sudden something the DJI pocket Pro
one-inch sensor uh new camera that's
dropping in December that's out now and
I'm like for vlogging that's probably
the best Vlog camera now it didn't even
exist a couple months ago and now the
whole thing so in your Niche and for
everybody listening I think there's a
big thing about perspective of course
Jesus said be careful how you see and be
careful how you hear if your eye is full
of light you know that light is going to
be great but if your eye is full of
Darkness how is that darkness that just
speaks to how much we we we get what
we're looking for it speaks to the power
of perspective and I get it I know that
a lot of people listening to this right
now might feel discouraged and
overwhelmed oh there's too much
competition oh like there's no videos to
make or it's all been done before um you
know everyone else and you could go that
way well that's a perspective but what's
the other perspective wow there's so
much opportunity wow if I skill up and I
take action and I apply biblical wisdom
about hard work and strategy if I
continue to sharpen the acts you know
the sons of isacar uh their skill set
that it talked about in the Bible was
they understood the signs of the times
and they knew the course of action that
Israel should take and so there's
something about seeing the signs of the
times AI seeing the different things and
then knowing the best course of action
to take okay so this is where the
conversation's going now this is where
the new topic is going this is this just
opened up a whole new series and for
some it just will take patience do not
grow weary in doing good for at the
proper proper time you'll reap a harvest
if you don't give up so sometimes maybe
you have like a tough six months or a
tough year but if you don't quit then
all of a sudden boom kajabi adds AI chat
jpt gets an upgrade you see the
opportunity because you're looking and
you're keeping the ax sharp you do a 50
part series and 100 part series legit
and all of the sudden you go from slow
and steady to like boom viral growth and
people go oh my gosh you got so lucky
you just blew up overnight and you're
like I mean overnight success takes 5 to
10 years I've been studying I've been
learning I've been positioning I've been
Skilling up but I've also been looking
for where is that unique opportunity
around my topic in my Niche to really
create some strategic content and that
thing can appear we can take action
today and get results today but also we
want to just be paying attention to the
opportunities that are going to show up
tomorrow
and I can't specifically say what those
opportunities are because we don't know
but I can guarantee you they're coming I
think Richard Branson said opportunities
are like buses there's always another
one coming so even if you miss one like
I'm sitting here being like we should
have made the video as the Canon M50
worth it in 2023 there's there is no
less than 5,000 videos right now that
I that think media should make myself
Nolan Omar Nathan now we're actually
recruiting content creators like we're
taking applications for uh think media
certified coaches and uh for recruiting
content creators and we'll link details
about that up in the description down
below of just seeing of of different
people in this case it' be specialized
in uh Tech or social media or things
like that but
ultimately uh there's 5,000 videos I'm
that's not a that's not an exaggeration
and I'm not going to tell you what all
those videos
are uh I'll share it inside of the V
group you know for maybe another tech
Channel but but it it is definitely
developing a set of lenses a perspective
that can see the signs of the times and
to know what strategic action to take
next and then figuring out the bandwidth
and the energy to take it here's the
good news even us with a big team and
video editors and stuff cannot keep up
with the amount of opportunity and so
less about me executing on those 5,000
videos people and we got to land the
planes so I get these other coaching
calls but almost everybody is
underestimating how much opportunity
there is right now on YouTube how much
white space there still is how many
uncovered topics there still will be or
just that not that there is but that
there will be but you won't be able to
seize them unless you actually develop
the mindset and the skill set to be able
to see them when they come so anyways I
hope that's uh helpful that was quite
the rant uh but uh Myra any was that
helpful kind of maybe shifting your
mindset definitely that reminds me of um
the verse 2 Timothy 1:7 I think like for
God has given us has not given us the
power no for God has not given us the
spirit of fear but of power love and of
sound mind and like I'm going to stop
cowering in fear and thinking like of
that like too much competition
saturation thing and I'm going to just
like get to work and um you know create
those videos like even that title um is
Canon um M50 uh worth it in 2023 I think
I could spin that off to like is think
kic worth it in 2023 or 2024 things like
that there are so many ideas now so
thank you you have unlimited Limitless
possibilities it's that's true so
anyways man I appreciate you so much
we're all humbled can we give it up for
Myra Kate by the way her channel is Myra
Kate just her name you can see it on
screen here uh can we give it up for her
though showing up 3:00 a.m. in the
morning to be on coffee with canel thank
you I mean I told you I
would I wouldn't mind if it's like like
at night or something yeah I would I
would wake up for think
media so grateful for you and thank you
so much for coming on coffee with Kel
thank
you all right smash like I feel like
that first one was good so let's stick
around to the end because we'll see
where they go from here we got two more
coaching sessions um but one other thing
I want to encourage you is we in this
last session talked about being ready to
seize opportunity you know again I think
that opportunities are like buses
there's always a new one coming but if
you don't develop the mindset and the
skill set you're not going to be ready
for the day of opportunity I think the
best example of that is David and
Goliath because um David was just doing
his day-to-day life he's tending his
father's sheep he's bringing his
brothers a shakery board at the front
line of battle he's not even a a soldier
and Goliath is taunting the armies of
Israel and David
overhears King Saul talking about what
he would do for the person that slays
the Giant and when he also hears about
the opportunity some people think David
is so faith-based and his ultimate Zeal
was for the Lord but he also heard the
king saying listen you're GNA get the
King's Daughter you're going to get your
taxes canel you're going to get a place
in the king's Palace so sometimes I
think we get a little too spiritual as
Christians not realizing like hey you
want to you want to build a YouTube
business you want to build a channel oh
it's all for the glory of God of course
but David was also like bro I'm trying
to get like the sick house I'm trying to
get the wife I'm trying to get my taxes
canceled that would be the ultimate
shout out to the IRS and so ultimately
you think about he hears that and then
he's like I'll fight him and then he
starts getting haters and and feedback
his own brothers are doubting him and
and you know it's like I'll fight him
and even King so you're just a boy like
he's been a man of war since youth and
ultimately tries on Soul's armor it
doesn't fit he's got to do it his own
way there's something about figuring out
your own way your own path your own
strategy for him that's the smooth
stones and the sling and then ultimately
he goes out and fights the Giant and
boom is able to have that accuracy hits
giant with one stone falls down he
approaches an old problem in a new way
and ultimately brings victory for Israel
and kind of sets him on this trajectory
to become King and all of the above
what's the point the point is he his
confidence was I have been faithful with
my father's sheep because Saul goes dude
how do you think you can go fight
Goliath let me ask you how do you think
you can go up against Mr Beast how do
you think you could go up against think
media what audacity do you have to go up
against this or that creator that you
see who do you think you are they're
already Giants they're too big they're
you can't overcome that
and that's sometimes the mindset that we
get but notice that David didn't just
say he wasn't just like oh um because I
said prayers in the mirror in the
morning of like I can do all things
through Christ like I can do this that's
important I'm not putting prayer down
that's critical but David said well
listen Saul I have been raising my
father's sheep and when the lion came I
struck it and when the beer came the be
the bear came I defended the sheep from
the the bear so I'm not afraid of this
giant the first day he picked up a
slingshot was not the day that he fought
Goliath and there's another verse in the
Bible that talks I think about the
gadites about how how much of Assassins
these guys were with the slingshots in
fact even future you go back a few pages
and it's like and a bunch of other
people kill Giants too with that same
methodology because they approached it
in a different way here's the bottom
line point I want to encourage you to
keep developing your skills to continue
to get small
wins for the next few months even the
next few years David was faithful to
develop his skill set and his mindset
he's writing songs he's worshiping he's
praying in the wilderness that actually
prepared him for the day of opportunity
and I think that the reason a lot of
people are going to miss their
opportunity is they're not getting ready
they just want overnight they just like
why can't I just blow up now well you're
not even ready to blow up you don't have
the mindset that's skill set or the
character you have to have that season
but look at your season as this
opportunity of preparation and
development they that are faithful with
little will be given much so if you're
faithful with the lion and you're
faithful with the bear then you'll be
ready to defeat the giant and so I hope
that helps because
ultimately YouTube is a marathon and not
a Sprint and if you're trying to if you
want to have future success tomorrow
invest today in Skilling up developing
patience developing your skills titles
thumbnails developing the ability to
research developing a strategic you know
Minds marketing brand a lot of stuff
that goes into this this not saying that
it's easy but nor is defeating Giants
easy but you can be ready for your
opportunity tomorrow if you spend time
preparing today and that's on our thing
man let's sharpen the a uh you know so
we're not exhausted with and frustrated
by the results we aren't getting because
the the blade is dull we got to sharpen
this thing and then all of a sudden
success becomes easier if you missed
that reference we started today with
ecclesi Ecclesiastes 1010 and you can
look that up hey today's episode is
brought to you by vid iq.com
think um we might pull that up on our
next uh coaching call here with uh Chris
and uh Megan but uh vid iq.com slink
will'll get you a free trial of the
Boost plan um listen number
one vid IQ is Nob brainer because there
is a free version so if you haven't like
downloaded the Chrome extension and
installed vid IQ what are you doing like
that's you know what's you know what's a
good price free that's a pretty good
deal so you could download vid IQ you
could get that vid IQ uh Chrome
extension but also boost is a monthly
paid program and I definitely recommend
it for everybody but specifically for
anybody that has momentum as you start
getting any kind of momentum or any kind
of money coming in one of the best
investments you can make is back in your
yourself back in your YouTube business
back in your YouTube channel and that
could look like lighting cameras that
could look like plane tickets to go fly
and collaborate with somebody or
interview somebody it could look like a
lot of different things but the person
with better
tools is gonna have an unfair Advantage
vid IQ is not a Magic Bullet you need
the mindset the skill set you still have
to develop the ability to create content
but it is a an assistant right and one
of the cool things about vid IQ is
whether it is their keyword tool which
is still powerful um you know it's
there's that search based content and
suggested based content you have um
daily video ideas which is incredibly
powerful tool and that is actually
connected to your channel so it's giving
you video ideas that are specifically
related to your channel you have the
ability to analyze other content that
your subscribers are watching so you
might say Sean how are you able to look
up these other channels and find these
competitors or adjacent channels and
different things and then make strategic
decisions based on that vid IQ because I
need better data I need better insights
I need better things coming my way but
probably most powerful of all is their
new AI coach when it's connected to your
channel like when you click these ones
with the little diamonds here based on
my channel what video ideas do you have
for me you might say Sean how is this
different than chat GPT well the
difference is it has a YouTube
strategy programming laid over it like
Chad gbt is actually the foundation of
their AI coach well I could just use cat
gbt no because they actually are
leveraging that technology but then
programming it with YouTube specific
data paired with analyzing your channel
itself so for example the answer to this
question is based on your channel data
think media I've come up with five video
ideas to align with your Niche and your
recent performance that's a power tip
right in the middle of the whole session
by the way though is like if you don't
have a niche then this coach and YouTube
itself is probably not going to know how
to help you because YouTube is trying to
say what is your channel actually about
so you're G to confuse even AI
assistants if you don't get crystal
clear on who is your Channel 4 what
problem does it solve and So based on
that um it's talking about top 10 growth
hacks for 2024 added to the list Drea
write these down um The Ultimate Guide
to YouTube seoa 24 also good and these
these are my specialties so those one of
the questions I like to ask is how hard
would this be for me to make like if it
would take you 10 years of research then
that's probably not the next video you
make but like right now I could probably
spot spout off the top 10 growth hacks I
have I definitely could talk about SEO
so five must have camera accessories for
Content creators how to create enraging
thumbnails that get clicks mastering
YouTube analytics the qy metric for
Success well Sean I could have like went
and figured that on my own fine maybe a
but B think about the speed of that I
could have just PR my next five videos
in the touch of a button so smart
entrepreneurs always understand that
they're going to buy back their time
with money I'm not saying that it's for
everybody but I am encouraging you that
if you're super serious about YouTube
success consider checking out a 30-day
trial of vid iq's boost plan and you
actually could try it for an entire
entire month for a dollar at vid iq.com
thinkink Link in the description below
as well um Nob brainer on that one and
uh I think that'll serve you with that
let's Lock and Load with our next
Channel no small life with Chris and
Megan Ria did I say your last name right
you did yeah you did which
is and thanks so much for coming on
coffee with Kel tell us a little bit
about your channel and what you guys are
up to yeah yeah so we basically started
a channel called No small life just
encouraging Christians that their life
is not small just in case they don't
look like everyone else's life for us we
call ourselves uh infertility survivors
so we didn't have the cookie cutter uh
Christian marriage or Christian life and
that presented some challenges to us and
we thought maybe we other people felt
that way and so we kind of started out
to create a channel on a nonprofit
really to talk to people whose lives may
not have turned out the way they thought
and kind of how to rebuild your life but
in that process we've kind of gotten a
lot of stuff going on here because I'm a
pastor my wife's a designer creative
communicator and so we talk about a lot
of things that have to do with Christian
lifestyle and Christian marriage we also
have a marriage course through kajabi
that we sell to people so we kind of got
a lot of things going on and that's what
we're we're trying to figure out is how
to kind of Niche down a little or is it
okay Christian Life out to have all this
stuff going on right within the
Christian lifestyle realm we really talk
about rebuilding your relationship with
God um your marriage and then just kind
of your practical life so those are the
areas we focus on like and like Chris
said we are marriage coaches and so we
lean a little heavy on that side um
we've always been gunshot to go
completely Christian marriage because we
have a lot of followers who are not
married because their pain Point look
different than ours so yeah kind of
where we're at it is separate out on our
social media channel so we have a no SM
Life channel CL work Channel with um
within Instagram and Facebook so what um
what is your ultimate dream
scenario what does winning look
like um as far as the content goes or as
far as just in
life well isolated to your media
Ministry let's call it that where would
you want your media Ministry YouTube
channel but like core social media
across the board whatever where would
you if three years from
now um you hit your goals what would it
look like feel like what would be
happening
and what would that look
like great question that is a great
question I I think it would look like um
our videos really solving problem I
think for us because we content creation
comes easy for us and we have a lot of
different areas we like to to talk about
and the Bible's filled with a ton of
topics that I think for us it's it just
feels right to like go a different a
bunch of different routes but in my mind
I would love to say we solved this
specific issue for this group of people
and they came to us and then they got
free but we've never been able to say
like like Dave Ramsey's the money guy or
Jimmy Evans is the marriage guy we we
don't know who that is for us and that's
that's why that's kind of a little bit
tougher sure but we know we're a
Christian lifestyle we know we want to
kind of stay in that Christian yeah I
really want people to be able to come to
us and feel we've always talked about
being like the mentors that we never had
for people um and so in a in a practical
sense too five years down the road I
would love to see the channel monetized
be making you know a significant income
off of YouTube and really creating
content that is helping mentoring people
in um in Christian lifestyle marriage
for
sure amazing
so one thing that that was as you got to
the end there we have a a decent level
of clarity if I was to score that on
like a one out of 10 on maybe like how
good your answer was to that question
your answer was a three or a four um and
so that's better than a zero and there's
some room for improvement there but I
want to encourage um Everybody also
listening that this might be one of the
most powerful parts of your day or of
your year and really a good time to get
ready for 2024 here's the question again
for everybody if if we were having this
meeting here three years from now so if
you're here live with me on coffee with
Kel maybe let's put that on your goals
list or if you're watching this and
you're watching an episode of coffee
with can three years from now from today
what needs to have happened for you both
personally and professionally for you to
feel happy what needs to have happened
if we're meeting three years from now
for you to be pumped excited and happy
like you felt like you reached your
goals and I think one of the work um
that you could do after this Chris and
Megan is take some of those answers um
to questions you said we want to
monetize the channel and really break it
down down
granularly um and if anybody wants to
grab a journal or take some notes and as
we know on coffee with canel uh if you
want to get your your pencil pouch out
and uh you could get you know your pens
your all that kind of stuff get get that
ready
because uh some of the things you could
write down is how much money do I want
to make per month how much money per
month um and then another question would
be is there going to be a team around is
it going to just be you is this going to
be sustainable so then it's also like
how how much money per month you might
go well this would pay the bills or this
would give us a little bit of margin or
give us Financial Freedom or a righteous
person leaves an inheritance for
children's children so maybe retirement
accounts and college funds are funded
but did you think about the expense of
maybe a thumbnail designer and some
other things well what's fascinating
about doing that research at the
foundation is again how much money I
need per month I know that sometimes
times Christians can have money mindsets
but a slight side quest here is this
could sound insensitive to some but
$10,000 a month is not a lot of money
right oh wow Sean that's offensive well
here's what I mean it's a lot of money
as personal income but for a business
owner 10,000 a month is not a lot of
money because the business owner the
self-employed um have got to figure out
their own retirement they've got to
figure out taxes is a different
situation and just because you have
$10,000 a month Topline that's not
take-home and I want to share this with
all of coffee with canel so sometimes we
set our targets too small and sometimes
our our mindsets are also too small
because we we were afraid of greed which
is not even really part of the equation
you know just give more like be more
generous and fight the spirit of greed
but like it's not greedy to want to make
25k a month when you realize you're GNA
employ other people you could actually
have more momentum you can make a more
impact because you need money for the
mission where there is no vision that
people perish but where there is no
money the vision perishes and so okay so
how much how much money we want to have
um we want to be helping people how many
people what kind of people and what kind
of results would they be getting uh from
watching your content you know we set a
vision we want to help a million Purpose
Driven people create a full-time living
doing what they love while making a
difference in the world with YouTube we
actually turn it into a mission
statement meaning there's an amount of
people there's a result they're getting
fulltime means
Financial Freedom or autonomy to do this
fulltime from home or for the business
owner they might already be doing it
fulltime but they need more leads
clients and sales so we understand that
none of this is going to be perfect but
as you increase your level of clarity I
think this would be helpful but then
probably the biggest thing is I really
would I think you were on to something
when you said Dave Ramsey is the money
guy you know so and so is the evangelism
guy or whatever there's a reason for
that you know this is not new
information Zig Ziggler said it's better
to be a meaningful specific rather than
a Wandering
generality and um even if that's not to
say because Dave Ramsey talks about
entree leadership he talks about
business he has other personalities
talking about marriage as far as the
Ramsay Solutions they're doing a lot but
he obviously could talk about a lot of
things but here's the key he got known
for one thing he cut through the noise
with one thing there's a powerful book
called The One Thing by I think Gary
Keller and and the Keller Williams
founder or one of them and so I actually
think it's it feels like you're kind of
avoiding marriage a little bit or you
don't want to get pigeon H hold that's
the mistake people make it it it
actually doesn't end up making your life
smaller it actually ends up making your
life bigger it doesn't end up making
your YouTube channel smaller it makes it
bigger if you pick the right Niche
furthermore I do think there's something
about you already have the course
there's something about potentially
creating a blockbuster product I don't
think I've ever talked talked about this
somewhere else but one of the ways that
people really become known for something
is if they create a blockbuster product
you got your work cut out for you to to
attempt that but if we think about
something like YouTube Secrets 110,000
copy copies sold I think you could
probably call that a
blockbuster there's a one reason why I'm
known as the YouTube guy is because I
planted my flag became known for one
thing not social media that's good too
but social media LinkedIn what Tik Tok
what are you doing Snapchat still
there's still a lot of people there um
but but like I planted my flag you want
to know what felt small it felt small to
narrow myself to YouTube it felt even
smaller I haven't told this story very
often was I think around 2014 or
2015 I wrote a book it was a eBook only
um but I wrote a book called YouTube for
churches
and not a lot of people know about this
I don't recommend anybody watching this
go by it it's not very good it was then
it's outdated I think is is what I
should say um but here's some of the
mindsets I had with this book I was by
the way I I designed this cover on
Photoshop Rachel Sneed who I was on a
church staff with was the editor I typed
it out in word I used this UB software
from Ryan dice to actually publish it I
just bootstrapped it on myself figured
it out um and I got it done well here's
what happened in on a smaller scale the
first thing was I was a director of
communication at a church and I
was nervous because I was doing social
media for the church I was leading media
teams I was doing leadership and I was
like I'm a lot bigger I do a lot more
like I do I do more Christian Living I
do a lot more than like just marriage do
I'm do a lot I do all the social
platforms we were doing some Facebook
ads I'm helping the pastor with his
personal brand I'm doing the church
media we're doing some TV and then I was
like I should write a book called like
maybe social media for churches and then
I was like but you know what I love the
most and I'd already YouTube is a search
engine I was already ranking videos I
was already doing some stuff I was
ranking
videos like Las Vegas Church Henderson
Nevada church I was using V to grow a
local church I had used it I was using
it for an author speaker coach I had
some freelance clients that was kind
part of my early career here's the thing
I was afraid of writing this book I was
like YouTube's already niched and for
churches what talk about Niche Within
what a
small that's too narrow man that's too
small the opposite is true when I
published this book I became the number
one expert in the world on YouTube for
churches and you go Sean how could you
have the audacity to say that well I'll
tell you why because I was the only
person in the world I the competition
was nobody
else only person and I could say that
like I'm number one they be like how do
you know I'll be because there's
literally zero other people that are
like specializing in YouTube for
churches boom I start doing some
Consulting I start getting flown out to
Florida start getting paid get put up in
hotels to come in coach by the way watch
this to coach churches and Ministries on
social media yes YouTube but it just
like now I became a meaningful specific
in a world of wandering generalities
so I actually now was uh getting invites
and getting on more podcast and getting
on different things because someone was
like okay here's the question everybody
listening this should ask it's like when
somebody thinks about something who do
they think about if someone's thinking
about man I would love to learn more
about sales I would love to learn more
about marriage I would love to learn
more about the end times I would love to
learn more about Deliverance I would
love love to learn more about who do
they think about when they think about
that thing and we we can see endless
examples of how powerful that is it
feels limiting but then what we also see
is just because it's limiting at the
start a lot of guys maybe got known for
evangelism or apologetics or something
once your world gets bigger once there's
more money for the mission your world
can expand Ramsay has now built an
Empire that has career advice can man
that has marriage and mental health
advice John Delaney that has more
financial advice Ramsey himself is
spearheading small business advice
Ramsay's not niched that's actually kind
of accurate like he's niched in in terms
of debt and cut your credit cards up but
Ram Ramsay solution is not n Sean's
wrong you you don't you don't uh
Ramsay's not
niched what like he's 30 years into this
people are making the mistake of
comparing getting discovered and
building it up to then what look what's
it looks like at year five or year 10
but the reason that people haven't hit
success at year five or year 10 and they
never became a meaningful specific so
that was quite the story but I do think
deeper than your channel strategy deeper
than those things and we could touch on
a few of those things as we land the
plane I think deeper than that is is
architecting where do you want to be
three years from now
where are you financially and and then
break that down how would those numbers
work back on the finances so how many
courses would you need to sell per day
or per month or per year and you break
it down of of your marriage course to
hit that Target if you're YouTube
channel and and don't get too paralyzed
writing out your goals be like okay what
that might be is 2K in ad Revenue 3,000
in core sales maybe some brands are
sponsoring our video podcast and that's
what's going to reverse engineer from 10
gram um I want that in conversation that
when it comes up that like oh they're
the and and what you add to it is you
might go well Sean Christian marriage is
already covered so then you go how do
you add a detail to the thing how do you
add an additional detail to instantly
make it completely
unique AKA YouTube for churches so oh
I'm the YouTube guy ah there's already
other YouTube guys okay YouTube for
churches okay now I'm the only one so
it's like so maybe there's a Nuance on
Mar that's the only book on marriage um
I just was with Rebecca zong who's an
expert in narcissist she never thought
she'd go there 400,000 subscribers she
never thought she didn't even want she
her Niche is narcissists she's a she was
a lawyer she actually loves negotiation
now she helps people negotiate with
difficult people but her most recent
book slay the bully is on negotiating
with narcissists don't even think it
exists it's
2023 and how could it not exist
we're still on that thing of opportunity
endless opportunity it's not easy you
got to master branding Master marketing
look at your Skillets look for the gaps
in the market but I think that I would
encourage you to really spend some time
asking some specific
questions around um and I I I I'm not
are you guys in V yes did you go through
Niche
Finder
we not yet I don't think I think we
started it and honestly we've we've been
we've been doing this for four years
it's the same conversation yeah we've
been in this conversation Loop for a
long time between us so I think we saw
that that was coming and backed out a
little bit because we knew this call was
coming so perfect well so a couple
things on that one thing is you already
have Niche Finder that is for sure your
homework that course right there I
believe prayerfully and practically okay
that doing those Frameworks having those
conversations and actually watching that
course together and doing the
accompanying PDF and
worksheet that of course is all about
Fierce CL Clarity number
two I want to encourage you and
everybody else listening that if I I'm
coming across it all
preachy or coming across it all on like
wow Sean just got it figured out like
Sean just this is so hard to get that
Fierce Clarity it sounds like he has
such Fierce Clarity well I would agree
to some degree but I just want to
encourage you exactly what you said
we've been debating this for four years
yeah we debate this in every meeting
like meaning for think media so so I am
I think it's less about Clarity and it's
about the pursuit of it and it's about
making certain decisions where um
branding and marketing I think is an
ongoing refining of your brand not
necessarily just like a moment in time
light bulb it's a constant Wht whittling
away as if we were chipping away Stone
to eventually reveal the statue of David
you cut off a little bit here a little
bit there and it's becoming clearer and
clearer and clearer and at some point by
the way I mean you already have 2,000
subscribers it's like you've already
have so many things to celebrate I
actually think the marriage thing by the
way because you're a couple and it says
well hi there we're Chris and Megan a
Christian married couple my my first
impression and obviously your cover
image marriage and relationships to me
that is kind of what like I actually
think your branding is really great and
the channel is great on a lot of levels
so it reminds me a bit of my journey
where you can even be in a place of
already having a lot of good things I
think you probably have more clarity
than you realize and sometimes it's
maybe about commitment and choosing to
just double down and actually publish
YouTube for churches or double down and
actually Niche down because maybe it's
more of a a fear rather than it is a
lack of actually having an intuition of
what to do but I just just want to
encourage you um if I sound like I have
it all together the opposite is true I'm
just in a constant Pursuit and I found
that the quality of the answers we get
in life is based on the quality of
questions so this isn't even necessarily
like an exercise we do once I'm
visioneering throughout the year every
year and also then asking okay not even
just what's happened over the last four
but really truly where do we want to go
next and the nice thing about the
three-year Vision the three years from
now is you also do have you have you
have full control of steering the ship
you make the decisions you make the
videos you public the topics you public
the book you choose to publish the
course you choose to publish you're the
one who's architecting your own brand so
you get to shape the narrative um and
let me know your next question though
has this been helpful at all this is so
good this is really good we we we
definitely appreciate you taking the
time it's it it's I know we've had these
conversations a ton and we really we
have found success but we haven't had
that one video and we kind of feel all
the time that we're being like pulled
around yeah in a lot of and I got to
become an expert at like the Bible at
mental health at marriage at design it
feels like a a lot to become an expert
and actually produce really good content
and all these niches but we also don't
want to like get bored in the marriage
nich you know and not help some some of
other people so it's it's just one of
those things
that's tough no I feel you and that
right there by the way as we land the
plane but this is uh I'm really glad you
brought this up
because
um life is really comple I just turned
40 so you got some wisdom from the
reflection I've been
doing uh in the weeks around my 40th
birthday
and I think there's a book called halim
we'll look we'll link it get up and uh
for anybody watching this I what is
officially halftime I'm considering this
a TR a triester if anybody wants to ask
me because I'm because I'm going to 120
so this isn't halftime but but maybe it
is and so Bob Buford he wrote a book
called halftime moving from success to
significance um call it anybody that
wants to get ahead or call it especially
if you're 40 like me or older take stock
of the successes and accomplishments
thus far redefine significance redefine
so that's something about redefining
maybe your Niche your future identify
your personal goals develop a mission
for serving God in the second half of
your life well there's two questions
that Bob Buford says will
really help your second half be stronger
than the first half the first question
is what really is my
purpose and like Rick Warren taught us
if it's not aligned with my purpose
purpose if it's not Purpose Driven how
can I actually start doing less so I
would ask you too what could you take
away because everything you just listed
so
elimination is is perhaps your chance to
your your path to growth as oppos as
opposed to addition I actually don't
think almost any human living with an
internet connection and a smartphone is
struggling from from not enough they're
struggling from too
much and then his second question is how
can I create the most Leverage
two questions for your second half how
can I focus what is my deepest purpose
and align with that and how can I create
the most leverage so that also begins to
there's been certain things that I think
about as there are quotes that say like
you're never too old to dream a new
dream or you know create a new thing and
I agree with that like there's all those
cool stories
like I think Steve Carell from the
office like really got started at 40
three or you know such and such Smith
Smith Wigglesworth the famous reviv
revivalist like got saved at 50 or
something so there really is that you're
not too old thing but there's also that
thing of that I even think I go man to
actually go deep and develop expertise
on a new thing be hard like you said
it's gonna be hard to become an expert
at Theology and on marriage and and it's
hard but I think I think that's for
anybody listening man how what are my
strengths what are my experiences what
are my passions what is my greatest
strength Niche Finder would really help
be helpful in this and how do
I create the most
leverage and and
focus creates leverage it's a laser
versus a shotgun it's
Focus allows momentum to build I just
got off a podcast interview earlier and
these days with gray in my beard I'm
talking about how I've been doing video
for 20 years and YouTube for 17
and I'm not going anywhere um I keep
doubling down it keeps building more
momentum it keeps it's a laser now I'm
also architecting there's many things
I'm passionate about the Bible a stream
like this I'm finding ways to you know
we're here at think media podcast
talking about the Bible like so there's
different things that can happen but
anyways I think that uh you know there's
lots of tactics and I want to get to
Stephen and answer our super chat in a
few questions but the cool thing is
because of being a part of VRA Niche
Finder you could continue with those
tactics yes titles thumbnails topics
architecting the videos your themselves
um and we'll we could keep that that
momentum going but I do
think that on the other side of like
focus and on the other side of of
developing that selfawareness and you if
you think four four years is a long time
I started asking the questions that
we're talking about right now I I knew I
wanted to package what I knew into an
online course I saw the opportunity of
that I probably had Fierce Clarity that
I wanted to do that in 2012 with zero
clarity about exactly how it would look
or why would any TR anybody trust me and
and once I knew that I went out and
built the credibility I was like I don't
want to um you know even have success on
YouTube Just teaching YouTube I want to
actually go fight some lions and some
sheep develop that cred credibility
prove my stuff works so on my personal
Channel I rank videos about grain juice
and rank videos about this and got some
million view videos under my belt and
then and then built up mainly Tech and
camera reviews and then event so so it
helped me
chart a whole life path 2012 I'm
thinking about that 20 2009 when my wife
almost died and we were in the hospital
um I I knew at that moment YouTube was
the vehicle I was like I know this
vehicle will work to pay the medical
bills to help us reach our goals and I
will until and I'll focus on that and
and then we went through a lot of hard
years I mean working at a church 2012
But continuing to learn continuing to
develop continuing to debate with
friends continuing to buy tickets and
fly to events continuing to research
continuing to wake up it feel like it
all makes sense and then getting so
close to the problem and being super
discouraged and being like my channel is
the worst my branding doesn't even and
some of that's just an it's not even
true but it's an emotional roller
coaster and so I just want to encourage
you
to just continue to pursue F Fierce
Clarity and everybody listening for
everybody that thinks it's like a magic
you
know uh holy water you could just splash
on your face wake up the next morning
and like I got it like I just I think
it's about architecture life
architecture brand architecture and just
keep refining it and and um I think that
that'll be a next couple moves and then
stick with Us close in V for the
specific tactics and I think your your
guys's future is really bright cuz
because you already have you got I mean
there you can see the Charisma the vibe
what you've accomplished the thumbnails
the creation of the videos the b-roll in
the videos uh this set the whole deal no
like be encouraged you've made so much
progress and have so much raw material
that you're building on um just keep
keep stirring that and it's kind of like
in a personal opinion specialized for
you is it's I feel like you're kind of
three feet from
gold um and so don't start stop digging
you know don't give up Before the
Breakthrough kind of a thing and I don't
sense you were doing that but I I feel
like you're a few moves away from really
architecting your next PATH and in
particular here's the prescription so we
end with some
practicals really work on that three
years question and granular
granularly writing out a uh a vivid
Vision I don't want to overwhelm with
resources because we link up half time
for anybody that that's interesting I
just finished the book uh Vivid Vision
which I'm doing for our team um and if
even that points a picture I think that
maybe the th media team would say the
vision's been clear for a few years
guess what I'm still working on the
vision Andy Stanley the visioneering
book like I haven't read one book on
Vision I've read five and I just read
this one so it's like continuing like
and so vivid vision is speaks to the
fact that a vision statement and a
mission statement is not good enough
that actually he encourages you to write
a
three-page vivid Vision that says this
is how we're going to feel in three
years and three years is the
timeline three years from now this is
what our this is what it'll look like
this is what it'll feel like this is
what our team will feel like we have a
small team five people uh we've built a
great culture and now because what I
also am asking we remember we
specialized this just for YouTube and
you said well do you mean everything
well that's that's the big question you
I think you write a vivid Vision about
everything and you start thinking um
okay our church staff is like this in
order for me to have a much time to do
media I actually have a successor um
who's being trained um he she is um a
great leader they have a heart for the
vision and they really want to help me
on that local church expression I have
got um we've got a small team we've
created two different entities uh our
our our YouTube channel and Media
company is an es Corp it's a nonprofit
whatever you want to do you know our
church is a nonprofit we've got this
director there we've got this parent
company we're living here we're living
in the same house we've bought a new
house it has a basement that basement
has 10- foot ceilings it's got our
podcast studio in it it's got this we've
got um we sell this many courses we have
this much ad Revenue brands are reaching
out to us the public says this about us
in conversations we were written up in
Charisma news or whatever we were um
talked about this because we about um
what we have shared in terms of marriage
we Vivid Vision it's about three pages
so I think you take it some time and and
then prayer on it's cool that we're on
this Christian coffee with canel because
we can talk more prayer more Bible and
in Proverbs where it says where there is
no vision the people perish or where
there is no um Vision the people cast
off
restraint um that word for vision is
chazin I believe and it actually means
prophetic Vision so it doesn't even just
mean a good idea it means a god idea so
I think in this entire pre process is
prayer and fasting a little bit you pray
you fast everything up in this point God
is using they are that is the entire
ingredients that he's goingon to work to
the good but it's I think that as you
maybe go Vivid Vision maybe halftime
maybe Niche Finder and you then you
journal and then maybe you fast and pray
that's kind of like an offering you lay
on the altar but I think the fire is
gonna fall and then I think you get kind
of like some Fierce Clarity around the
whole thing like what does it all look
like and what piece does this have
because everything that everybody that's
listening to this we're the YouTube
people but it's Bigger Than You YouTube
is just a vehicle all it actually is is
like ones and zeros that turn into
visual images and audio like it it's
just a vehicle what's the business
what's your life what's the product
what's the impact what's the message uh
eron mcmanis on her podcast just said
everyone's storytelling is this big hype
and I said how do you tell better
stories and he said story living is more
important than storytelling meaning like
the the substance that ends up on
YouTube you may be talking a little bit
deeper about the fights you've never
shared the times that maybe I don't know
you locked the door like slept on the
couch I don't know if any of that
stuff's happened maybe more vulner like
some stuff comes out like man the
Breakthrough is when there's another
level of vulnerability another level of
transparency another level whatever and
you capture all of that this has been a
great
conversation because I'm for everybody
listening I hope because man especially
as we also get ready for 2024 what a
blessing on November 14th to maybe take
some time right now to capture Vivid
vision for those of us in halftime to
think about halftime to get clear on our
Niche and to really get clear um about
about where it is that we want to go uh
I think that could be helpful any final
thoughts or
questions I I mean I'm we're we're just
very grateful to be on with you Sean for
your your feedback for your
encouragement to speaking to not only
what we said but maybe what we didn't
say that we were feeling too so we
definitely appreciate that feel like we
got a lot of wisdom so thank you and
we're GNA do it we're we're all in we're
we're excited to be part of v and learn
more and and grow and we're doing it
we're moving forward well I appreciate
you so much and thanks so much for for
coming on and I'm so excited because
maybe someday online again like this or
at an event I can't wait to hear about
the Vivid Vision awesome thank you
forward to that too all right hey take
care Chris and
Meg all right well thank you Stephen
Brooks for your patience we're going to
get into that in just a second what a
session today I hope you're having a
great time smash like if you're getting
value we're talking about YouTube tips
and strategy for Christian content
creators we kicked off the entire stream
with an axe Ecclesiastes 1010 using a
doll axe requires great strength so
sharpen the blade that's the value of
wisdom it helps you succeed as a side
note let me know in the comments or in
the live chat if you would ever want to
buy an axe like this what I was
wondering um was every year at think
media we um we have a theme of the Year
this year it's built to
last last year was at our uh at our best
uh inspired by K new Hoff's book at your
best that's a great series on the think
media podcast we'll link that up in the
description down below um we shared my
interviews with him and we shared my
talk from our our staff our verse then
was Proverbs 4:23 guard your heart above
all else for it determines the course of
your life but what's funny is I thought
about I was like man these things are so
cool what if like like Peter McKinnon
does like limited runs of things and all
it says on here is think but like I
don't know let me know if you're
interested in
if you want to buy an axe not that we
plan on doing that I was just curious
but what are we talking about I think
there's something so powerful and I want
to thank you for being here especially
as a Christian content creator Pastor
leader um you know about taking some
time to sharpen the blade and sometimes
we want to run out there see like in
that last conversation I think maybe
with Chris and Meg we want to run out
there I'm G post a video make a
thumbnail come up with more content post
the title run out there and sometimes
we're running out there with a dull
blade and we haven't taken the time to
really sharpen the acts what could that
look like well of course in wisdom it
says to to the value of wisdom it helps
you succeed so how do you get wisdom
well in a multitude of counselors and I
mean I guess that's what we're doing
right here it's a coaching call you're
learning and a multitude of counselors
you could learn from Cameron heral Vivid
Vision we got that book Bob Buford half
time our Niche Finder like so multiple
with multitude of councils plan succeed
before going to war get good advice so
of course there's getting advice of
course there's uh practicing like just
getting out there and hustle not you
know a lazy man uh says Ah there's a
lion outside I'm not going to go outside
right I mean but it's like it's stepping
outside of your comfort zone it's
practicing it's it's doing four years of
posting videos and that's sometimes
maybe your Wilderness
season it's your season of getting the
Wilderness is not useless the Wilderness
is where David was killing L protect ing
sheep killing Lions uh fending off bears
and getting prepared for the day of
opportunity right the Wilderness season
really prepares us for the public season
I like to encourage people to use your
season in obscurity to prepare you for
popularity you think your small YouTube
channel is a burden it's actually a gift
your small YouTube channel is you
practicing in public your skills the
nuances of YouTube like titles and
thumbnails practicing thumbnails
practicing graphic design and video
creation practicing communication
practicing you're killing Lions you're
killing Bears you're getting ready for
the Giant and so if you use your season
wisely in obscurity It prepares you for
popularity and I think I don't really
get to talk like this if it's not a
stream like this one but you know I
think that sometimes popularity is
overrated too of course well Sean I need
the money I want to go full-time yes but
sometimes an inheritance gain too early
in the beginning won't be blessed in the
end so times your small YouTube channel
is actually more of a gift because
you're not ready for Success yet a lot
of people dealing with
failure in my opinion is easier than
dealing with success I don't mean to
offend anybody but I've seen success
destroy a lot more life than failure
ever has so sometimes all the lessons
and all the practice and all the study
and all the things you just want to
stick with it because those are the
ingredients that are preparing you to be
ready to handle the pressure and the
growth and the momentum
well Sean I just want a viral video what
good is a viral video if it's 15 minutes
of fame but you don't know how to
sustain it because you never developed
the character or learn the skill set so
I don't actually I want to go viral but
but if I had an option I would rather
have slow and steady success rather than
viral
success I because I I don't want my
inheritance too early in the beginning
because I want it to be blessed in the
end you know behind the gold play button
over here aperture 1.4 on my Sony lens
so it's completely blurred but this
picture behind me over here says slow
and steady winds and at the end of the S
is a little turtle Gold Leaf UGM monk
UGM nk.com if they have an affiliate
program like I don't even know if they
do but uh ugmonk does these uh these
images this one says never settle
someone said it said someone thought it
says uh never
Seattle like wow what does he have
against Seattle so that says never
settle so this one says slow and steady
wins and the turtle at the end of the S
is uh is the tortoise and the hair right
see everybody wants to be the hair in
2024 they want to be fast fast growth
fast viral problem with the haite was he
was cocky was prideful he thought there
was no chance the turtle was gonna win
so he ran a little bit took breaks and
the turtle just slow and steady ended up
winning the race the tortoise in the
hair after this stream I got to order
that book for my son I read him three
books a night 20 minutes a reading a day
at least and we
uh uh I want to be the hair I mean I
want to be the the turtle I don't care
takes five years 10 years I prefer that
because if it's develops 15 20 because
what if you then have Decades of
sustained success instead of Boom we
went viral and I don't even know how to
repeat it boom we went viral and it went
to my head pride comes before the fall
so anyways I hope some of that stuff's
valuable we're going to get into our
final coaching call we got your super
chats and your questions I want to
remind you today uh is coffee with can
is brought to you by expand good
kingdom.com I am going live later today
now there is a limited replay um we may
make this class on demand so if you're
watching this video sometime in the
future just check out expand Goods
kingdom.com we'll put a link in the
description down below um we're going to
do as much YouTube tactics on this next
coaching call as we can but if you're
specifically interested in a three-step
like three big tips and a lot of nuance
strategy specifically for Christian
content creators that want to start and
grow YouTube channels if you're a pastor
Ministry Church or a Christian content
creator influencer you would love this
free class it is at expand good
kingdom.com and and by the way you know
well Sean you know it's free but is it
really free are you gonna sell something
yeah we have something for sale it is
called video ranking Academy we've been
talking about it in this very thing but
whether that's right for you or not
that's just our way to serve people at
the highest level that really want to
essentially enroll in an online YouTube
college that you can take on demand
that's our online course but listen
whether that's for you or not don't
worry about it like that's that's the
way we run stuff here at think media
like I'm not trying to trick anybody or
like what's like on the class you're
going to probably get about 80 minutes
of super of of YouTube tips and some
really powerful scriptures because I'm
kind of a Bible nerd and uh and then and
then I'll let you know about our program
and I'll do live Q&A and it's going to
be a lot of fun so if that sounds
interesting to you expand Goods
kingdom.com I wasn't trying to flex I
just thought Bible nerd just you know a
student of the word of God and I by the
way we have seven core values that think
media the first core value is the Bible
is our blueprint and so for us um I mean
technically we're we're not a Christian
company we're a company I love God I'm a
Jesus follower uh we have all kinds of
diverse people working for our company
and so anyways um what's the point the
point is on that class we're going to
share a lot of biblical and Bible based
principles that are critical I think for
building the kind of success that a a
Believer cares about because this could
be a little bit different right with
your values your beliefs um but then a
lot of tactical strategy stuff for
YouTube so anyways expand God's
kingdom.com is uh the link for that link
in the description down below and then
shout out I know a little while ago we
got a Super Chat Thank you new kind of
just delayed a bit but still worth it to
join could seem like a silly question
but how can I imple Implement religion
into my
Niche so um this is a great question I
think a couple couple answers and then
we'll get to Stephen and then after that
we'll do a little bit of Q&A with
whatever time we have and let me just
look over here on my calendar to see
okay I got a little block for recording
but it's nothing crazy okay so I got
some time here so how do I Implement
religion into my niche well a couple
things um I'm assuming you want to
that's based on the question I mean
that's obvious but I guess I I would
challenge Christian content
creators that you don't have to I
believe that's that's biblical that you
do not have to uh meaning the maybe
first question to ask would be is it
necessary because I actually think
it's neutral if not harmful if it's
forced personal opinion I don't mean to
rule any feathers out here but I
think adding forced Christian e into
business is unnecessary maybe it works
that's meaning I didn't call like think
media is not Christian camera
reviews so I'm not trying to implement
religion into our Tech
videos and that's kind of what I mean
now then me just describe my then and
and I think that making a Christian
Channel if your channel was
titled you
know Bible study Millennial Bible study
well then obvious that's incorporated
into your Niche now I looked up your
channel new kind of and I see you doing
some like a drawing of Last of Us okay
so I see it seems like you're drawing
you also did a best gift ideas Amazon
links in the description maybe it's like
is that for drawing so I think actually
even getting clear on your channel is
one thing but I think the question that
comes first is is is it going to be the
most effective thing and and what is
behind the question do you want to
encourage do you want to implement
religion into your Niche because you
deeply care about the Great Commission
great you should unfortunately a lot of
Christians don't so great but then even
still so let's take it to businesses
it's like if you're a pool cleaning
company like does it have to be like do
you have to name your
company uh the pool of Beth Betha
cleaning company or could you just be a
great pool cleaning company and the way
that you connect with and serve your
customers and the Excellence that W that
which you push across you you put
across um leads people to get to know
you and when appropriate you're able to
share your faith that's what I mean is
it's up for you to architect and that in
some cases by the way why I also like
when people I don't like when people
like call their you know Christ's
carpentry incorporated or something is
it also if you're not excellent at what
you do and you don't actually treat
people right but you're like but I want
them to know about Jesus and it's like
was that a good witness or was it would
have been better not to know this is why
I don't put any Christian bumper
stickers on my car because sometimes I'm
not super saved when I drive it's just
kind of TR it's sort of true I mean it's
uh can I be real like
uh and so I'm like if I you know I don't
know if that's going to be the best
witness like I know that I just have
sometimes a Need for Speed I'm I'm
working on it I'm working on it so I
think thinking about how is it you want
to get your faith across and and then a
little bit of two cents just answering
this question of how to incorporate
religion in your channel I think you
kind of have a couple options option
number one is you go overt overt is like
it's Bible study it's Ministry it's news
it's Christian
commentary the other way covert sounds
it's just the opposite of overt I
suppose but covert would just be maybe a
little bit more like think media meaning
it's just like it's not branding I mean
the Bible is our blueprint is pretty
overt but like that's only being said
here on this stream and it'll be said on
a website and other places but back to
the point of like if you make a promise
in a title like in one of your recent
videos was best DIY gift ideas am Amazon
links in the description is like
what does that now here's a way you
could incorporate best DIY gift ideas
although if you said one of them you
know would be make a scripture picture
well the viewer might be like that's not
what I came for or you could incorporate
they oh this person's probably a
Christian one of five things could be
Faith related so are you g to be overt
in your branding it's like a a channel
for Christian couples or it's a Bible
study channel are you going to be just
more of like you solve a specific
problem and your faith is woven in at
certain touch points in certain places
um you know and and how are you going to
do it and the way I do it is we kind of
mainly weave it in I realize that
individual videos we did a podcast a
while ago advice for Christian content
creators um we're doing this stream
we're doing this one up we are we just
launched these new expand Gods
kingdom.com to serve Christian content
creators directly but our business and
our bigger brand again it's a little bit
more Broad and last example I'd give is
I would encourage you to really follow
and study John
Maxwell um one because of getting into
leadership is always helpful even if you
don't consider yourself a leader but two
John Maxwell has kind of become known
probably is like the foremost
best-selling leadership author uh in the
world right and very well known that
he's a Christian but very respected
across in different circles the way he's
set up he's got some nonprofit stuff
that doesn't have the Bible evolved so
he can impact the education system he's
got some for-profit stuff it's really
cool but he also has a John Maxwell
leadership Bible and you know someone
came up at a leadership seminar and said
John where did you get all your
leadership wisdom from where did all
this stuff come from and he goes if I
tell you you're not GNA like the answer
and he goes oh really he goes yeah you
want me to tell you and the guy goes
yeah I want you to tell me and he goes I
got it all from the Bible um the guy
goes yeah you're right I didn't want to
hear that because obviously the Bible is
the greatest success book of all time
it's more than that it is the very word
of God it's truth it's inspired the
entire you know all scripture as God
breathed and inspired and useful for
training you and me for the work God has
for us and so anyways what John has done
is he's added value and served people
and then realize that he'll sometimes
add an extra session at Advance and say
hey now that I've taught about all of
leadership stuff um would you if you
want to come back to a special session
tomorrow I'm going to share a little bit
about my faith which is ultimately the
secret weapon I mean it's the fuel and
the fire of the whole thing if I'm going
to get my success to anything it's going
to be that come join me and he does you
know alter calls um in in those events
sometimes he just does them in main
sessions and I think he said that in the
last couple years there's been like a
million like the last two years there's
been like a million decisions for Christ
and the pace they're at with the scope
and size of his company there's like
going to be a million every two years if
they continue doing what they're doing
and I would say there is nothing about
this book that is Christian in The
Branding or the title and on most Pages
Bible's quoted other people are quoted
but that's why John has been such a hero
to
me um
and because of thinking about just
different ways to express your faith as
a Christian content creator so it's a
really good question I thank you for
bringing that up and I think that could
serve a lot of us here in the sense of
like how do I Implement religion into my
ni
and I I want to relieve some who also
feel a pressure to overp spiritualize
meaning this business is not just a good
idea it's a god idea and it glorify it
says in Colossians I think whether you
eat or drink whether you work like do it
all into the glory of the Lord and you
making a video that answers a question
you entertaining somebody of course your
content being aligned with the ethics of
scripture but you got to pray about it
and think about it you know of course
you should maybe share your faith with
friends and family and people in your
world but one of the ways you can
glorify and serve God is just make great
videos that get people results make
people laugh bring people a little bit
of Peace bring people and and really
pray about how God wants to use you
because you don't want to try to wear
Saul's armor armor maybe somebody else
is like really good at Theology and
really good at evangelism and really
good Romans is clear Corinthians is
clear we all have different gifts you
want to get clear on your gifts and and
and how how God's going to use you in
some cases of course share your faith
but even the gift of making money is a
spiritual
gift and so that you can help build
God's kingdom and so not that if that's
all you did because in and of itself
that's amazing but if you have Clarity
the question is okay I clearly can see
that I'm good at business I'm good at
marketing I'm good at branding maybe
better way to put it I have raw talent
that needs to be developed in those
areas so let me develop that deep let me
just get Crystal Clear Focus I wna I
want to help fund churches I want to
partner with Tim TBO and help end sex
trafficking I want to do these different
things and I just want to go really deep
and make the best content possible and
if incorporating religion was a weird
forced thing like just forcing you're at
a Mexican restaurant and they just like
here's some sushi as well and you're
like what it's really weird if I wanted
Sushi I would have went to the sushi
place and they just like kind of force
it on you sometimes I think Christians
make the mistake of doing that like it
doesn't even really make sense and it
feels more like a Jesus
Juke than effective Spirit-filled
Ministry so just a few thoughts I know I
went a little long there we got to get
to Stephen smash like friends if we're
getting value today and uh Pastor
Stephen Brooks from Stephen Brooks
International is up next Stephen welcome
hello Sean how you doing hey I'm doing
great thank you for having me on today
thank you so much for coming on thanks
for your patience for an hour and 35
minutes and 14 seconds um as we were uh
getting ready for this uh tell me a
little bit about what you're up to when
you started your YouTube channel what
your ministry is doing well it's
interesting because uh on the 30th of
this month will be 10 years exactly
since the day that we started our
YouTube channel but I've got to be a
little bit honest I felt like um we've
had it on autopilot you know I would
upload a Sunday message and a Wednesday
message and not give it much attention
but we went to the armed media
conference that you spoke at and
Charlotte and I tell you for my wife and
I the reality of it really came alive
and we said we're going to get serious
with our uh Ministry YouTube channel and
uh since that point we've joined V and
every time you talk talk and uh share
something that I can apply I like the 1%
rule that you mentioned that every time
we upload a video just try to get 1%
better so um but we are a little bit on
a plateau I want to get past to 10K I
want to hit the 30k and uh break through
to the uh 100K so um we are ready to
make those adjustments and make those
tweaks and uh give it what it
needs um I love it and and thank you so
I was actually just on with Evan and
Allan Dido this morning on a zoom call
so I'm so grateful we got to connect at
armed conference I'm looking forward to
next year and um okay so let's talk talk
about it so I think number one it is
cool I did look up your channel congrats
also on over a million views 1.1 thank
November 30th 2013 so you're no joke
it's this month 10 years ago let's let's
check out a little bit of your oldest
video here we go here's the oldest video
how to increase in God's favor okay we
got the globe yes another inspiring
message and there you are yeah
480 yeah I know this is what is
resolution is this I mean I think it's
480 so and it looks like it was
stretched it went to widescreen from
like the normal uh maybe letter letter
box and who even knows what's happening
there I love this this is cool to see so
um on live stream uh you know before
YouTube got more and more popular there
was like live stream one of the uh
initial initial like streamers and uh
they didn't have 1080p streaming just uh
low
res it's absolutely wild and so uh I
love this and so um okay so let's talk
about the channel let's look
so now are you also uh full online
Ministry is it local church are you
teaching Sunday and Wednesday and then
uploading how are you doing it we're
mainly uh Apostolic uh prophetic
Ministry we do a lot of Television but
we had to face the reality that while
television is a niche field and we've
we've been blessed in that area uh
YouTube is just where it's at and a huge
segment of the support of our ministry
pours in through our YouTube viewers and
so we've got to really um just beef up
what we're doing with YouTube so uh but
outside of that we do a lot of ministry
we travel a lot and uh preach and uh
write books anything we can to keep the
ministry moving forward in the sense
that we're not evangelist our ministry
is mainly to the body of Christ to build
up those that are already in uh the
church so we we have we have a lot of
people that watch our YouTube channel
not only in America but also like we
have Ministry Partners in China uh
Australia and uh just many distant
places of the earth so we're like a
online Church many people consider me
their International Pastor there's a lot
of people in the church that fall in
between the cracks and uh maybe they're
in military or maybe they're a truck
driver and they just cannot attend a
regular church and so they find us and
they get fed spiritually and then uh
through the platform of YouTube of
seeing the messages then they connect
and become partners and you know want to
be an online member and it just
continues from
there I appreciate that context one of
the things that's unique about coffee
with canel is context because rather
than just how to get more views it's
about your specific
situation um the first thing I'm going
to go two things and then I'll kick it
back to you for follow-up questions the
first thing that sticks out to to me is
I would love a little bit of work on
topics and I would love for the topics
to maybe get back to some um some
practical desires and some we we call it
asq answering specific questions okay
um that your ideal audience is asking so
the problem can be like a fresh
infilling of the spirit of faith is not
it kind of gives me Clarity of what it
is if I follow you I know what that is I
have to already know what the spirit of
faith is maybe I have to know if I want
I want to watch that or I have to
already like you no like or trust you to
want to click on that um so the the flip
side is if when you answer specific
questions it could be like even what is
the spirit of Faith this can give you
series to do but even more than that and
and my favorite thing to type in
is like what does the Bible say about
now by the way like this is probably
going to take what does the Bible say
about Israel what does the Bible say
about masturbation what does the Bible
say about tattoos what does the Bible
say about so then you start getting into
like okay so what are people really
asking well by the way the answers are
right here like it partly what does the
Bible say about Israel and that kind of
TAPS into a little bit of trend surfing
now maybe you don't feel called to go
there or feel equipped for
the intensity of that situ you know like
do you want to jump in but by the way
what is on people's minds right now uh
this war this conflict what does the
Bible say and that kind of also reveals
to
us take your channel out of the equation
for everybody listening to
this oftentimes the reason people
struggle on YouTube is because they're
making videos that nobody's searching
for nobody's looking for and it's not
the right word in the right
[Music]
season like there's chyros timing right
and there's Kronos Kronos is the linear
time chyros is the now word well okay of
course now it you got to be you're
following the spirit so you're going to
talk about whatever you feel led to pray
about what you're studying but when some
like
pastors the apostolic misses out on like
side like what does the Bible say about
Israel it's like if anybody if you
unless for some reason you're like I
don't feel qualified to answer that or
just don't feel like that's right for me
like 100% of of of churches should be
answering that question because what is
every on everybody's mind and that's
that is a lightball moment for any Niche
because when something happens that you
should be talking about and you're not
talking about it then don't come to me
later and complain that you didn't get
the views because that's where the views
are so it's also kind of like you know
of course in a church sometimes when the
relationship series happens all the
young people show up and unmarried
people show up it makes
that versus they don't if maybe another
series shows up again you got to follow
the spirit of God but when you match the
right message at the right time the way
we say this is that the YouTube Creator
who understands the viewer best wins
and if you know what keeps them up at
night what are their pain points what do
they want to learn about what are they
dealing with and so then I think getting
back to practical reaping and usually
large Harvest is a four-word title can I
be bold with you yes please I mean on a
scale from 1 to 10 I think this title is
a two okay reaping an unusually large
Harvest so let's let's Work Sharp Shop
this a little bit reaping an unusual
large Harvest so let's
uh let's think about other ways we could
say that um
let's go to our vid IQ AI
coach and let's reaping a large Harvest
tell me if I'm
correct um is this biblical principles
for money is this teaching on tithe and
offering it does cover the area of the
30 60 100 fold return but the conditions
that surround that to get the best
return okay and so maybe the other thing
looking at that I like saying
is um I learned from interestingly
enough I was at a conference
that Donald
Trump's marketing
manager was speaking at who
ran his campaign the year that he had a
victory over
Hillary
objectively what we know is that Trump's
messaging and branding and
marketing was far better than Hillary's
you remember what a slogan
was uh let's see here well we know to
make America great again exactly right
that's what it was right what was
Hillary's I don't even remember Nobody
Does even her fans don't know like her
messaging wasn't it didn't it didn't
resonate it wasn't clear right so this
guy was running
Facebook ads ad spend marketing for
Donald Trump and I'll never forget we
say it in BR now we all the takeaways
this is also the power of attending
events because you get like one nugget
that's like can be absolutely
lifechanger sure and he said you know
one of the things that what we
realized was that when it came to our
messaging we needed it to be kitchen
table talk Ah that's the phrase okay
kitchen table
talk and what that means
is what's on the mind of the average
American as they're having dinner what
are they talking about with their spouse
their kids their family their friends
that are over and what language are they
using in marketing we learned that we
want to communicate at like a fifth
grade reading level Max eighth grade one
of the things you could do if you have
an AI tool is you type in you could type
in a period of text and you could say
can you make this fifth grade level of
understanding a lot of people on YouTube
Don't understand this because so so now
kitchen table to reaping unusually large
harvests if that was kitchen table talk
you might think it's a farming reference
you have to be like Insider charismatic
to know what that is you're ex and if
you were only talking to charismatic
super fans you would understand but
that's where we get back to maybe
saying
um so if we go in here and we say what
are 10 title
ideas for a YouTube
video
about what the Bible says about
money and then we hit enter let's just
see what spits out of so now if you're
following V if you're in the reverse
engineer research phase you kind of know
that the answer to the question is this
is how you reap an unusually large
Harvest and you know that
what what Harvest means is actually make
money is Is wealth is riches and you
know that reaping means gaining the
money and you know that how to do it so
so not only could I think even this
exact title be better but I also think
the entire angle could be better so top
Bible verses about money and then by the
way in doing research this will always
happen to all of us you maybe know okay
this is where I'm going with this
training you still know that I'm going
to teach on 30 6800 fold but
you also might in the process of using a
tool like we're using together right
here you might be like top Bible verses
about money discover the secrets to
wealth and prosperity you might go let
me add that to my list because I I can
make that video next week yes that's a
great idea yeah and now you might not
want to talk about Dave Ramsey's
biblical money principles but that's on
there you got biblical principles about
money how Christianity shapes financial
decisions the Bible and money unlocking
the secrets to financial success in
scripture so let's just stick with that
one and there's all kinds on here and
this is the um vid IQ tool but like I
love this
title Bible and money unlocking secrets
to financial success in scripture maybe
it's not a 10 but it's like an eight
that's like a nine in terms of clarity
people on kitchen table they know the
Bible kitchen table they know money
kitchen table unlocking the secrets they
desire financial success and they know
it's G to be based in scripture so we
have reaping unusually large harvests
versus Bible and money unlocking secrets
to financial success in Scripture did
you see how powerful that is oh it's way
better yes it's way
better so uh what I would also encourage
is this why this is why doing the right
things in the right order is so
important
because if the the the seven R system
right yes that before we press
record we want
to uh reverse engineer and research and
then write an outline and figure out
what we're and this means that going
into the third R which is
record we actually have already written
the title and we figured out so we even
know how we're going to hook the video
like okay I know that my title
is um Bible and money so now even in the
hook I'm like so what does the Bible say
about
money is there secrets in the Bible for
having financial success what's the
difference between the Prosperity Gospel
and the real
gospel um or you know and is it okay for
Christians to be wealthy and Rich and it
or you know whatever so you might now
the hook is better it's tied to the
title you then it's going to influence
the way you communicate and I would
imagine that your essentially hour-long
sermon that core content doesn't even
need to be switched much here's what
we're talking about we talking about
packaging yes Packaging
and content is King that core content
content is King but marketing is Queen
and she runs the
household and so it is it is a Christian
content creators ministers like yourself
I believe responsibility in stewardship
to really learn marketing and branding
as missionaries because the degree and
skill that you have at
packaging that's going to be title
that's going to be thumbnail that's
going to be the very topic itself and
that's also going to be the opening
because all of that is the package even
the opening of the video because if if I
don't quite understand I'm in the right
place during the first couple of minutes
one of my biggest pieces of advice for
uh pastors that actually post sermons to
a local congregation is their opening of
their sermon should be an architected
YouTube hook yes like they should spend
a lot of time maybe even practicing and
mastering the first 30 seconds if not
the first three minutes or something
because it's going to be an hour why not
take three minutes to do the hook right
opening
word uh you know so you're like all
right turn with
me
like as we get into the sermon today I
want to start with a
question what does the Bible say about
money by the way if you edit that and
put it on YouTube you don't have to say
it as we begin the sermon like so you
could cut it and it's what does the
Bible say about money now you're talking
to the local congregation but you're
hooking the beginning and you're like
did you know that Jesus talks more about
money than any other you know and and
then there's a couple things so you're
you're teasing what's to come you're
getting you know you're setting it up
and then you might go let's start with
our scripture today turn with me to
after three minutes of maybe a story
some questions a few points some things
getting people ready to consume the rest
of the content that would be packaging
okay that would be packaging to think
that not only do I have to deliver the
gift wrap the gift you know when they
then not they need to open the gift then
they see even the Box the gift is in
they still got to open the box and then
they get to the meat of it and a lot of
times we are focused on the meat of it
which is the most important too because
if your theology or the actual content
wasn't good then that would be our own
issue but I actually would think here
with your legacy everything you buil
everything that's here mastering
packaging coming up and in V we call it
the perfect video recipe okay uh big
idea hook content transition transition
just means at the end of the video
pointing to another video using your end
card and there's some a lot of tactics
we go deeper on so all that to say I
think to me we broke down one of your
videos and and maybe flipped how we
could do a better
title thumbnail is going to be
influenced by all the above and so
really mastering those first two hours
can be really helpful uh Stephen what do
what do you think about all that well
it's interesting that you pick that one
because that would be one of the
specific titles that when I created it I
did not feel comfortable with it and
sometimes you also feel the the time
pressure and your mind works and I'm
going to really start to uh lean more on
vid IQ and get the help that that AI can
supply because when I'm trying to come
up with the titles sometimes I can get a
good one and other times I could work my
way to a good one but on that one
honestly I didn't feel that solid with
it so I think it's amazing how you would
pick that one I think the Lord is really
helping me in this area through you
right now because uh if there's
something I feel maybe is not fully
baked I need to um cook it some more or
something till I get that ironed out so
that the packaging is more
presentable yes and yeah Stephen I I
mean I appreciate you so much and I
think that uh that we've we often say
small tweaks lead to Giant
Peaks and and sometimes that's a by the
way that's a small tweak in the
packaging that is proven in business
this it was the same product different
packaging now the product's
successful um and so sometimes we might
think oh is it my people don't like my
content I'm just not good enough it's
what's oh it's so it's capped here at My
Views when no the content's good uh but
it's the packaging content is King but
marketing is Queen and she runs the
household packaging and so um yeah and I
would encourage you keep going through
uh V and and and just like you have
mastered the
skill of hermeneutics biblical
interpretation that you've invested your
life in building all these things the
cool thing about what we're talking
about it is it is that it is learnable
and it's learnable relatively quick it
doesn't all the Clarity doesn't come in
overnight maybe not even in a year but
through diligence and discipline you
know 12 to 24 months from now studying V
and here's what's kind of cool for
Ministries churches Christian content
creators
um
we this is a it makes us it we'll have
better service to the body of Christ by
learning marketing here's why you know
Charles Finny the famous revivalist said
this he said you know when it comes to
like my Ministry I want the Bible in one
hand and a map of the human mind in the
other oh and so it it isn't just this it
is but if Paul said you know like show
yourself to be an approved Workman it is
Paul said I become all things to all
people that I might win some yes that
would be a willingness to learn the
culture understand the culture learn
YouTube learn packaging learn marketing
so that I can win some and
I have found by the way marketing is
kind of a funny term
because who it's kind of like sales like
Christians we don't want to be a a
marketer we don't want to be a Salesman
I don't blame people you don't want to
be a youth car salesman I don't want to
be a marketer I think the mistake we're
making is we
forget that Daniel spent three years
under babylon's Education Without
compromise so m Shadrach abedo Daniel
they they spent three years learning all
of babylon's tools and methods I
actually think Alan Dido was talking
about this you know David eventually and
this we talked about this earlier David
eventually used Goliath's sword to cut
off his own head so he used the enemy's
technology to defeat the enemy now he
used his his sling I guess he might have
already been dead who knows maybe he was
just knocked down and knocked
unconscious from this uh sling and the
stone but then he used Goliath's sword
to chop off his head so all that to say
is I do think as spirit
filled Bible based um anchored in Christ
Jesus
followers we have to guard our heart
above all else I think we have to be
careful that we do not use the words the
world's
um especially mindset you know because
we think different we're from a
different Kingdom so we're not of The
Same Spirit like we're not coming from
the same like we guard guard your heart
from greed and guard your so we need to
guard our heart but too many Christians
are afraid of like oh if I go to a a
secular conference or something and they
swear or if I if it's not like Christian
email marketing I don't want to do it
it's like no it's just email marketing
you know like it's it is Goliath sword
that could be used to you know to uh for
God's kingdom and so there's something
about learning Mar learning branding and
even being willing Moses the same learn
from Egypt like I think getting an
education and the practicality of
packaging
right makes us like Charles finny saying
look listen scripture is the foundation
and nothing I'm not going to use any
tactics or anything that's in violation
of scripture but I there is something
about learning from quote unquote the
world to find these just Universal
principles that when apply will
ultimately lead to reaching more people
that's the whole point of the stream
that's the point of expand God
kingdom.com ultimate goal is how do we
reach more people for Jesus how do we
help more people with Biblical truth how
do we fight the fight of tyranny that's
happening here in America and around the
world how do we stand for values and
principles um bible-based values and
principles how can we be um wise as uh
serpents but harmless as doves how can
we be shrewd as believers and so all of
the above I think applying to our
content can be very very helpful any
final questions Stephen well I just uh I
agree because what you're saying is that
uh these are things that ministers have
to learn uh nobody told me in
ministerial training or ad ministers
conference hey learn how to uh learn the
flow of YouTube Nobody's teaching that I
mean we you have very rare exceptions
but they're almost like outside of the
church like the armed media conference
uh uh so uh these are things I've
learned I've got to dive into I need to
learn this and with your help the
learning curve is not that steep I my
wife and I were watching V uh every week
and those things are helping but um uh I
would ask you with a question about my
my theme or my vision which is stated on
the front of the uh YouTube my YouTube
channel unlock the power of explosive
faith and embrace God's best uh your
thoughts on that because I do see the
value of uh continually drilling down on
Clarity of vision I feel like I could
still refine that I wanted to get your
feedback on that
statement it's a great question I think
um I recently
changed hours because also YouTube on
thi media podcast because also YouTube
changed the about page the about page is
gone technically the about page is right
here it's a popup now okay and you still
have that section but you get the
preview of it I'm very glad you're using
yours preview so here's the most recent
one I I wrote for the thick media
podcast unfiltered YouTube tips for
building a profitable
Channel perfect that's about as many
characters as you have I encourage all
uh viewers and uh listeners that fills
the character count let me go to a
character
counter um and let's see here if I if I
paste the the text
there uh nope hang on so I'm just
curious because I want to give the exact
number so everybody watching this should
come up with a description for your
channel that is unfiltered YouTube tips
for building a profitable channel is
about as many characters you have that's
eight words 58
characters so you got about I think it's
I think it's 60 characters if is the is
the max actually let's type yours in
there yours pushes it a little further
so let's so maybe we have more than I
think because you fit the whole thing in
there as that Top Line at least on my
screen this word counter has seven
zillion ads on it okay here we go um so
we got 50 oh yeah it's 59 so I think
we're Max 60 characters okay so how can
you communicate your vision and your
promise of your channel who do you help
what are you trying to help them
accomplish um
in 60 characters or less and that's the
new text headline of your channel it's
that first line by the way the mistake
many make too is a lot of times it's
like welcome and then it's a space in a
new line and all it says there is like
welcome or it says welcome to think
media which is unnecessary
because it's an echo of your title here
and your handle here so anyways so some
homework for coffee with
canel okay so unlock the power of
explosive faith and embrace God's
best is on a scale from 1 to 10 my gut
reaction is it's probably a six maybe
six and a half it's not bad okay what um
some
advice rattling
off
um things that I look for when it comes
to like a clear elevator statement um a
clear elevator pitch a clear tagline you
could call it sometimes this is your
vision statement
sometimes it's just the short
description of your channel like we
don't have to overthink it what is my
mission maybe it's not a mission it's
just it's like what words can I put
there to best encapsulate my what my
channel is about um I like to
avoid
generalities okay
so I like
to like explosive
faith faith grow your faith is a clear
thing explosive is a nice word for
that's why it's still like a six and a
half or a seven it's good it's a nice
descriptor unlock the power of explosive
faith I also like to avoid if possible
anything that'll create confusion in
your average
viewer so that I think that for a lot of
people pursuing stronger faith and and
Believers like you said you're more for
like in the church people that want to
go deeper in their faith I then also
that's why the kitchen table talk
changed my life so much I like to
think if somebody that was old school
salt of the earth you're sitting at
Thanksgiving with your grandfather you
know my my stepdad Phil escalin he was
just here we had a 40th birthday party
we're sitting in the backyard like I
love how he communicates because it's
like short sentences it's so clear I
realize I overt talk and and how he he
might experience something and he'll say
like 60 characters he'll be like that's
what it is and he'll be like
um yeah it's it's a YouTube channel that
helps
me make my faith
stronger and I'm like it's a good point
it's exactly what it is and I'm looking
for fancy words so I'm not saying that
was a good tagline but I am saying okay
fifth grade reading level kind of or
kitchen table talk language that
everybody uses and then something
specific easy you could call it easy for
Ramsey to say he helps you get out of
debt or it's personal finance Christian
Living P it's a category it's specific
embracing God's best it's kind of like
all right but that's kind of why it's
not a 10 to me right because it's not
exactly it's maybe getting clear
on you know and by the way if we went
specific you could say um helping you
understand and apply the Bible great now
you might not actually add this to a
tagline but if you want to start being
uni unique you know how interesting
denominations can be different
viewpoints of the Bible our friend Alan
Dido his channel makes a lot of sense to
me because it really does feel it feels
heavy prophetic and it feels end times
yes so end times to me is is a is a
Clarity Clarity prophetic is clar you
know and so and that's what yours is as
well like so but those are some of the
things I think so to recap can it
be can I avoid generic language and and
find specific language can I can I what
exactly am I helping people on this
channel do how could I be known for
something more specific is it kitchen
table talk how can I find unique words
or power words to
enhance the the core thing there so
again I know I want to do YouTube tips
that's
basic unfiltered was the word I really
looked for to kind of be like raw
unfilter and here we are I mean I asked
you for permission it's you know so one
so in the first three words even the
first three words unfiltered YouTube
tips is pretty strong like okay that's I
would love some unfiltered YouTube tips
but then I think about features and
benefits what is your desire so then
it's for building what for growing your
channel true but one of my specialties
and what I hope is I'm actually trying
to find help people get all the way to
the point of profitability yes right and
to use the word profitable is again one
word so unfiltered YouTube tips for
building a what a profitable Channel
what I mean you don't don't
pH don't flatter me on a scale from 1 to
10 and in fact chat do it as well on a
scale from 1 to 10 how clear and what
what is the how good do you think this
is is how clear I would say right off
the bat that's that's a nine but how
long did it take you to get that were
you working back exctly no by the way
those 60
characters I've also been doing this for
a while so it did take it took me maybe
30 minutes maybe an hour I spent
probably an hour okay and then kind of
seeing how many characters I had kind of
thinking about what it
was but but how I spent a decade it's
real I spent a decade to get prepared
for the hour
okay because I I mean branding and
marketing is what I do for a living so
it came a little bit faster but it still
took some time so I appreciate that so
it's so it's like a nine and I also kind
of I I just wanted a new update because
I was I realized it was outdated and I
think and wasn't even showing up
correctly I think if we go over to think
media and uh we might want to remind
Kyle it says thanks for checking out
think media on
YouTube like so that's that's a absolute
waste of space right there thick media
TV thick media Drea if that's not
changed by the end of the day Donald
Trump you're fired just just kidding
relax relax uh she's might not even be
there I see her in the background um and
so like what are we doing we are YouTube
coaches but I I I I took over I did the
podcast Channel where was Steph when you
needed him you know and so ultimately
um yeah so I appreciate that I'm going
to see what what the live chat was
9.74 11 I mean and y'all are flattering
10 I appreciate it so on on a on a on a
scale from one to 10 how clear is the
description so that's what I encourage
you to work on and that has a little bit
to do of clarifying where's the Lord
calling you to go where's he calling you
to teach and and I went back to that
thing if if you if you use words like
charismatic or prophetic or
Spirit-filled be more that's clearer for
me okay CLE that's clearer for me if by
the way if you also go uh
uh uh what would
be what was like Mark Driscoll and Mark
reformed reformed carries a lot of
weight okay spirit filled means
something uh and and so you know
Spirit-filled Bible
teaching and and actually the process of
doing this step is
also and for everybody watching open up
a fresh Google doc H write
down your first
one spirit filled Bible
teaching to help you
reach God's best I don't love it but
write it down because then that's the
first one and so then you go spirit
build Bible teaching on the next line
and you're seeing with how many
characters maybe you end up writing one
that's 100 characters and then you say
what mve what words could I remove right
so then you're
like spirit
filled Bible
teaching for daily
life right okay boom another one and
then you keep going and then and the
next thing would be to bounce it off a
couple people which one do you like best
hey hi hone which one do you like best
and I have one other tip for you and in
our 2our and 10 minute and 50c stream so
far which I still probably have five
questions I'll get to
is I have one more tip for you that's
very important please um and that is you
got to use your community tab more ah
you haven't posted here for a year it's
very old yes but here's how I'd
recommend you use your community tab
watch this you could write your final
three or four
best taglines opening lines for your
channel right here okay then you post a
survey a poll on your community Tab and
you let your subscribers vote on which
one they like best oh that's cool I like
that you got 10,000 subscribers okay
what I would encourage is actually the
way you're doing this was also the way
we teach like a you know Big Image and a
link to the YouTube video that's good
too
but what I I saw this earlier what I was
thinking um multiple ways you could use
this I want to see how long it's been
since we've posted a Ser a a poll over
here but the thing with Community tab a
lot of times people are using it too
much for
promotion like promoting a video they
should be using it more for
conversation okay and audience
feedback in fact we
are and this coffee with canel is our
public opportunity for realizing that I
mean and actually no we are doing good
like uh when we ask question so there's
two and two specific ways open-ended
question um so this it says what is the
best freebie you've received that's
interesting and that'd be like a lead
Magnet or something like this but here
so here's the here's the open question
for anybody that has a decent amount of
subscribers and a community tab with
anybody responding what is your biggest
pain point right now what is your
biggest question about the Bible what is
your biggest
what topic would you like me to cover
next you could do it as an open question
all you do is po look how easy this is
it's it's some
text but better than that or in addition
to that you also might say okay thinking
about teaching on reaping the big
Harvest and so I'm gonna use vid IQ AI
coach I'm gonna I've I've narrowed it
down to three titles four titles now I'm
going to go to my community Tab and say
which of these title
resonates with you most and then you
create a poll okay and the way and then
and all you got to do is you go text
poll and you say you copy first one here
so we had uh we had Bible and money
unlocking the secrets can't actually fit
the whole thing that's only 65 character
limit unlocking secrets to financial
success you don't even need in scripture
actually come to think of it because
guys the Bible is already clear so so
you leave that one then you go number
two now here's what I've learned
if you have even the smallest sample
size like 22
votes it usually Maps pretty closely to
the Big Data okay meaning meaning like
literally what would get the best
clickthrough rate at a big scale can be
identified with a small sample size of
surveying your audience okay so that's
so here so that's here's an example of
what happens so how do you prioritize
when designing a thumbnail I have not
voted on I'm on think media so I'm not
logged into this podcast faces and
expression branding colors bold and
readable text high quality
imagery H
I would just say high quality
imagery um and so then you see your
answers 3933 and that was uh 1,200 votes
punchline is when I have done surveys
I'm trying to think about one of the
last ones I did was probably about a
title
is in 10 minutes I knew the
answer um meaning before all of the
answers came in it could have changed to
be fair but I'm just saying like it it
happens pretty quick this is maybe which
title would you click through quick this
is the last time I did it which title
would you click first mind-blowing viral
video secrets from an ex YouTube
employee X YouTube employee reveals
secrets to viral growth try these viral
secrets from an ex YouTube employee try
these mindblowing viral growth secrets
from an ex YouTube employee and actually
that got caught off which was fine right
now notice one by far outranked the rest
in terms of
votes and I got 1200 votes 1,200 votes
but here's what I'll encourage you even
with 10,000 subscribers and even if you
only get 50 votes okay my point is that
small data and big data in this case
doesn't change much and that this title
won
in the first 10 minutes now it's been a
month um and was that's how fast the
community tab can help you get a little
Clarity because you're like well I'm
gonna ask my wife but like does she
really you know I mean that's one that's
only one how do I get some feedback and
an empathy for someone if you're just
starting your channel you can't tap into
this as much but for you with 10,000
Subs getting audience feedback what
questions are they asking what do they
want to see next voting on a title and
in doing so every time I do this I feel
like I get a little bit smarter it just
a little it's another it's life's all
about creating data sets and the more
data sets you have in a particular Arena
like I just have looked at more videos
and more thumbnails and more clickr
rates and more titles and more backend
and more affiliate programs and more
launches this a lot of different data
sets and those data sets have helped me
write maybe a
9.76 level Channel tagline in less than
an hour maybe you take somebody else a
week but it's because of how many data
sets and how much refining I've done
over the last decade in terms of this so
anyways the application for you is tap
into the power of your community Tab and
start doing it today like these posts
they may might take five 10 minutes to
craft but the simplest one would just be
asking a question and I and you you
could post on your community tab
technically as much as you want three
times a day is not too much so even
daily you could just be asking your
audience more questions what what's your
biggest challenge right now
what what is a a a Bible question that
you would love to have answered what
what are you struggling with because
when I say the Creator who understands
the viewer best wins how can you really
understand them unless you ask and
unless they answer that's
true Community tab okay I'm gonna
develop that thank you Ste man I
appreciate you so much thank you so much
for coming on coffee with Kel did you
get some value out of this conversation
oh yes and thank you for being so
patient with us and uh giving us the
extra mile this is really uh you came
with the sharp axe today hey that's
right uh that's probably what happened I
got the axe out and we were ready to
people just jumping on are like what is
he doing like you know but uh I
appreciate you so much I'm grateful for
you maybe um uh we'll get to cross path
again in the future I'm sure we were
will and keep building love what you're
doing and excited about the future thank
you Sean we sure appreciate you app
app appreciate you Stephen and thank you
coffee with Ken we're going to answer
some questions but as usual I got a
Super Chat I'm G to shout
out it's time for aha moments if you've
been here for two hours and 18 minutes
number one you're a real one number two
you're amazing number three in the live
chat unless you're driving and you don't
have the ability to type it out I'm
curious what is an action item what have
you like best from today what's an aha
moment from
today what's a a light bul moment for
you we've talked about Ecclesiastes 1010
using a doll blade requires great
strength so sharpen the blade that's the
value of wisdom it helps you
succeed so what wisdom did you gain
today what are you g to implement what
are you g to
try smash like if you're getting value
as a
reminder GNA take a little break uh
after our two hours and 18 minute stream
and a little bit later I'm going to be
doing another two hour stream starts at
three is that s soona
starts yeah so that's exciting um and
I'll rest a little bit but uh drop some
aha moments because we're not just about
information we're about application
fifth grade language yeah I've taken a
paragraph um you know put it into vid IQ
AI coach and said make this like a hook
I'll write out like five sentences for
what I want to say in the beginning of
the video and I'll say make this fifth
grade language even if it just gives me
a little insight oh yeah that sentence
was sort of clunky and confusing and
more advanced like great fifth grade is
really good um definitely working on the
description great yeah 60 characters
fifth grader language I don't have a
Christian Channel but as a Christian I
appreciate the value awesome appreciate
you thanks for being a part of V thanks
so much for being a V fan yes Community
Tab and and focus on community tab is
one thing for views it's more about the
data and the feedback that's the missing
Point everyone's like let me promote my
videos more and promote my stuff
ask better questions the quality of the
answers we receive in life is directly
proportional to the quality of the
questions that we ask awesome got vid IQ
amazing aha Don't Force Christian
content because it could be a net
neutral or net negative yeah no need to
force it totally fine but figure out
your brand what's God calling you to
do what's what Niche is he calling you
to do I think about Mary's Nest you know
one of our beloved Mary's nest and I
mean it's may be obvious in certain po
points she might mention scripture
mention this or that but she just she's
got almost a million subscribers she's
about to hit she makes just
great cooking and bone broth and and
apple cider vinegar videos and whatnot
but they're not like Christian apple
cider vinegar videos even though brag
right has that John verse uh you know
beloved I pray that you prosper and
being Health even as your soul prospers
um but that's the thing too the reason
people buy brag apple cider vinegar is
because it's good and the process of
doing it and it's cool they can kind of
you know put a Bible verse on there I
think it In-N-Out In-N-Out had Bible
verses I think they're may be gone now
but they used to put that on the
packaging so sometimes you could do
things like that but yeah don't always
have to use that using the community tab
features in vid
IQ um so amazing yes sustainable Pace
Jesse appreciate you um expand God's
kingdom is happening in the next 90
minutes apparently uh which we knew and
so let me just hit this Super Chat how
much do you Vet companies you want to
produce content for I've had push back
in comments about promoting Tech from
oppressive
countries well that is a really good
question um because that's a whole
another
angle
of of is the product
good is the service good and then how's
the service
made um the country could be impressive
the the the methodology of building it
you know I suppose in the lineage of
Nike if you wear Nikes at some
point there's a legitimate case to be
made that like you're wearing maybe
shoes that were made unethically or on
the backs of so I think some of that's
going to be a personal conviction issue
we heavily Vet companies I I'll I'll
admit that we have never looked into
their Employment Practices now mind you
I guess what a lot of times what we
promote is software and maybe they're
developers so I would maybe flip it if
information has come out like if they're
just from an oppressive
country I think people are like
splitting hairs over that because if I
was born in a country and I founded a
company there that has a great product
and a great service and I'm doing my
best to build that product and service
and I have like a dictator or tyrannical
leader I mean you know I don't have much
control over that shout out to the
entrepreneur and the founder of that who
did it on the flip side if even after
Corrections someone if yeah we're
accountable for what we know so um so we
wouldn't if if we if a company had like
a ton of smoke around them for being
unethical we would consider that for us
we do have an extensive filtering system
number one do we believe in the product
number two is the product
legitimately is it effective is it a
product we would use number four it
would we recommend it to our friends
family loved ones and family members
number five um do they have a good track
record you know number six do we see
longevity in the I've I've avoided we we
canned a podcast episode with an
interview of a founder of a course
hosting PL platform the episode didn't
go it was all right but I realiz and we
could have could have been lucrative to
promote this thing as an
affiliate but when I thought about how
many developers they had I thought about
the directory of the company and I
thought about it compared to like kajabi
and other things I thought let's let's
not promote this one because it may do
well so I was asking about the longevity
of the what are people investing it what
are they buying and will that company
still be along or or will they just this
is one reason why I love
kajabi that's what we use to host video
R Academy if you want to uh grab our
free trial we'll link that up in the
description if you're thinking about
hosting an online course and also want
to do all the things in one
platform but there is one reason why I
can I can vouch for for job kajabi about
others they have more developers than
than um thinkific and the other
companies you can fact check me but I I
think they're the the most sophisticated
most developed comp company that doesn't
necessarily mean they're the best but
why is that an extra layer is the
product good does it work good is it
also is it going to keep working good do
they have an infrastructure this is also
one reason why I like vid IQ over
tubebuddy tubebuddy hasn't been
like the interface it hasn't really it's
clunky like it hasn't been whereas vid
IQ continues to innovate and adapt and
AI coach and can and so all things being
equal business is sometimes ruthless a
little bit but if to buddy I don't know
what it is now because they were
acquired but like if they have 10
developers or 20 and vid IQ has 100
where are they going to be in the future
you know like so so which horse are you
betting on you know so anyways we
absolutely ask questions you've just
added another question to the thing uh
which would be yes does this company
have any drama or exploitive practices
or anything that we should you know it's
pretty good um and so and and then I
would finally say Ryan that push back I
would I would clarify push
back one comment isn't necessarily push
back 10% of your comments 20 or 30 or
50% of your comments that's push
back um Christians can be people
Pleasers
disproportionately we really can you
know we want to make people happy Jesus
was so Meek and he was so kind and he
was so he was so Meek and you're like
the Jesus who literally took the time to
weave a whip and go into the temple with
money changers and flip the tables that
Meek and kind Jesus like same Jesus so I
think that um we can become overly
sensitive and we don't have a good pain
tolerance for people disagreeing with us
for Christian content creators you need
to know right unfortunately Christians
can kind of be real they can kind of be
the worst and what do I mean they can be
the worst at at like uh being mean to
each other and infighting and like
splitting hairs over non-essential
issues well you took that scripture out
of context it's important keep it in
context oh I can't believe you use the
message paraphrase oh I can't believe
that's what you believe I can't
dude relax like one body One Church one
Spirit yes like let's debate let's
discuss but let's not lose our decorum
and become infighting and nasty and
weird and unfortunately a lot of
Christians get that way so if if someone
is like deeply researched to discover
that an entrepreneur in Korea somewhere
made an incredible product but the
country is oppressive and they're likei
cannot believe that you would now you
might explore that research that always
pivot and adapt with the times but if
you get one comment well sometimes it
spins us out tear the video down don't
post it I can't believe and it's sort of
like okay noted but again if the video
gets 50% dislikes and I think where
that's going to more
happen you probably would see it coming
I think that people you know
meaning you knew like people who promote
stuff like you knew theu like wasn't
that great you knew you hadn't tested it
you knew you were going for the money
and and not the thing like if you do
your best and apologize when you make
mistakes to stay in Integrity to be as
truthful and honest as possible to
promote the things you believe in it's
that's not going to be a mistake free
recipe seven questions to ask you know
is it valuable would I use it has it is
it from an exploitive you know you ask
all these questions you're doing your
best um but I think where where 99% of
influencers who get backlash is because
they promoted like that remember the
titles thing Irish titles or Scottish
titles or Noble titles and they got a
lot of heat because of like you're gonna
own you know a square inch of Scotland
you're actually gonna have real EST real
estate of a noble you can add uh that
you could add like Lord Sean Canal to
your credit cards you could do all this
different stuff and then that whole
company got under scrutiny and and
people this happened a lot with the FTX
and crypto and all the financial influ
influencers which I also don't even
fully blame because they may have done
the research and looked at and F FTX
looked good and now Sam bakman freed is
sentenced to over hundred years in jail
like I think that it's about doing your
best trying your hardest you know having
a filtering system apologizing when you
get it wrong and moving forward and not
being too tripped out by uh you know
uh oneoff comments I hope that's helpful
uh
fararo um what's your current setup
camera and lens is it possible to know
it's a little bit pricey we can we can
throw this up I'll let Victoria build
this out so first we have
two Sony fx30 is
fx30
second on this camera camera one we've
got and why I say we I I'm here by
myself sitting at my
house um we've got a Sony
lens 24 mil 1.4 G Master it's pretty
pricey it's like $1,200 lens we then
have over
here a Tamron zoom
lens that is uh 20 to 40
so it's a zoom lens
2.8 it's then in a Mac a Blackmagic ATM
mini pro which allows me to just plug
the HDMI cables which full size come out
of the fx30 reason I went with those is
because some Sony cameras have trouble
overheating I wouldn't worry too much
about it in a lot of cases but I'll tell
you this these cans have these cameras
or Cinema cameras they have fans inside
of them and I was like listen I want to
build like indestructible setup this is
a mission critical thing I do right here
I'm going to get the fans in the camera
you know that was how I made that
conclusion um we also already had one
that we were using over at Anderson
Studios and now we're these are crop
sensor cameras so we have full frames
over there so I got one I added another
one got the lenses I've got you naazi
ball heads on there and that's G be a
lot of things to maybe Circle back on
but I will list all this Tech in the
description I've got
um mounts to mount them to the desk and
then I'm using streamyard to stream so
yeah that would be the ATM plugs in to
USB and then I have a camera source and
then I just
have a switcher actually right here in
front of me and uh it's got the USB it's
got power and it's got the two HDMI
cables that and pretty much all I do is
just switch between them like this
however it would be a bigger blessing if
I started using you know I think these
transitions how great was that
transition did did you enjoy that how
about that one so there's kind of some
cheesy cheesy transitions how about that
little squish one huh that's nice woo
what a little squishy so Kyle was dying
because these transitions are so
ridiculous this one that's not as bad
that's kind of I think I've seen like
James Bond use this little like fade
slide those that the squishy one is
probably the worst this one wow I that
was um and so I don't need any of that
stuff so I pretty much just leave it on
Cut and I just cut between it and
um we'll link those up so okay listen
friends uh I'm gonna I got a couple
super chats thank you so much for your
your a second Super Chat to follow up
new kind of and here for a moment
unfortunately I legit Victoria is
telling me I need to rest we've gone two
hours and 33 minutes we are waiting to
get in live streams and we have a vision
but we are overwhelmed with the process
and thoughts start before you're ready
um do a live stream make it unlisted if
you want uh practice practice practice
practice practice practice practice um
if you also want to practice somewhere
that in your opinion is lower Stakes I
challenged a minister an aspiring
minister to go live on Facebook multiple
times a week I said why don't you at
least
weekly um why don't you go live on and
the here's why I said Facebook because
maybe it's not about building up the
library of videos on your YouTube
channel you're just looking for a place
to practice Instagram live it disappears
right when you're after if you don't
save it but here's what I was
encouraging him to do sometimes people
who aspire to be in Ministry are like no
one's giving me the mic no one's
inviting me to preach Sunday why can't I
when are they going to see my gift and
my talent why can't I speak and get on
the mic why can't
I you ever heard that or maybe you think
that right why am I not getting invited
not realizing we're living in a
world
where you could study the Bible and pray
and prepare a message and deliver it in
public to zero zero viewers or two or
six on Facebook or Instagram or YouTube
live and you can make it unlisted
after and here's what I encouraged
though as I said don't you think if
you like because you want to speak
Sundays and prepare a message every week
so what if as your Hobby and hustle
because this is the the thing you want
to do what if you just decided I'm
preaching 52 messages this year give
yourself a break I'm preaching 40 I'm
gonna share like 40 sermonettes once a
week I'm gonna go live and I'm gonna
share it or teachings or sessions or
whatever you
know and then what would happen if you
committed to that and who would you be
and what would your skill set be at the
end of those 40 days 40 weeks maybe you
do one a week how much would you have
grown how much would you have grown as a
communicator especially if you kept
learning and kept studying I think you'd
be an entirely different person here's
the sad thing he did it for one week
maybe three but he stopped no I mean no
judgment it's just
observation but I think that that's
that's the Difference Maker right like
that's it's not even just like stepping
out in faith and punching fear in in the
face and doing it that's a big deal it's
hard then it's not even doing it a
second time it's also not just
committing to like V or learning or
whatever like learning some kind of
system or methodology but like really
stick with it and really stay it through
consistency patience put in the work use
your season in obscurity to prepare you
for popularity what happens on the other
side you go this guy on this coffee with
Cel shell told me to start going live
once a week because I have an Aspire I
want to share my message I want to
preach I want to teach I want to do it
so I started doing I started doing on
YouTube do it on YouTube how many people
watch zero how many replay views
four cool I did it for two years and
what started happening is right around
the beginning of year
three started getting like 100 views of
video started getting 200 views of video
year five I'm an International
Ministry wow just overnight success just
came out of nowhere just because I
prayed and God bless me yeah or maybe
and we don't rise to the level of our
goals we fall to the level of our
systems that is a
system V is a system but the that would
be a system of personal development I
don't know how fast my skills are to
develop and how quickly I'm going to
grow as a communicator but what is on my
calendar that's going to force me to
prepare each week to deliver each week
is it going to be a non-negotiable see I
got to show up and preach on Sunday
that's why he stopped oh if if I get
invited to speak at my church on Sunday
well I'm not going to miss it because
it's in my city and I'm going to drive
down there but if I
commit to going live Tuesday Morning
from 7 to
7:30 online and teach super discouraging
that only two people watched Super
discouraging that only and they it I was
watching the numbers and I saw one and
then I saw Zero for most of the time and
then I saw three and then I saw Zero
super
discouraging
and I did it for three weeks but then I
started being like man this is kind of
hard and I'm not really getting the
feedback I want
and no one's actually making me do this
and I don't have to show up on church on
Sunday so I'm going to skip a
week I'm kind of busy I'm gonna skip the
next week I don't know it's only three
people anyways was it really worth doing
man you you gave up on your dreams that
easy you gave up on what you were
thinking God called you to that
easy sad there's something about just
not quitting there's something about
maybe setting it up by the way and
because this is a personal development
goal you're measuring the wrong thing
the success wasn't how many viewers it
got that's a results goal you were
measuring an action goal the success was
doing it the action the results are up
to God my action is 7:30 7 7:30 every
Tuesday I am going live and delivering
the content but that's a pretty simple
system fits on a
napkin what what did you decide I
decided on eventually there's like 26
kids in the youth Ministry and she'd say
hey we're about to uh we're about to hit
the recording you know that back in
these days they put like the sermon on
the CD or like maybe uploaded on the
internet she'd say okay here's what I
want everybody to do I need you guys to
scream like there's 2,000 people here so
the recording sounds better now you
might think that's too secular or
something it's not spiritual enough I
think that's actually exactly the kind
of mindset God would want us to have
because it's us thinking big in small
places and US acting big in small places
and us stewardship being faithful with
the little but treating it big because
I'm going to show up and go live for the
two people as if I had two million I'm
GNA prepare I'm gonna pray I'm gonna
fast I'm GNA get ready whatever kind of
content I'm gonna I'm GNA sharpen my a
I'm gonna learn my skills and I'm going
to do that over time and those who
do over time are the ones that develop
the skill sets Master live streaming you
know get comfortable with it learn the
things upgrade as they go so I hope that
helps friends thank you so much uh
Victoria said Famous Last Words last
thing probably a better way to put it is
as I land the plane and we do land here
uh she's saying have I finished my
slides yet I haven't and I am going you
know live in one hour and 13 minutes so
we are ending here so hit like join me
so we can keep this party going at
expand Gods kingdom.com Link in the
description down below that's where
we're going next I appreciate you being
on here today like maybe tag or share
this with somebody it really would mean
the world if you maybe you know somebody
they're a Christian content creator a
pastor a church shoot them an email send
them a link to this video you know um DM
them a link to this video just because
um it really is our mission here
especially to help purpose-- driven
people like you sharpen the axe and so
if you got some value today it would
mean the world if you liked and shared
my name is Sean Kel rhymes with YouTube
channel appreciate you can't wait to see
you in a future video subscribe if
you're not subscribed and we will talk
soon you